what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
in we have a special panel tonight but
before we get to that a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first is that we have two clips
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily make sure you go subscribe to both
of those sign up for our membership
tears follow me on Instagram and thank
you for 800k and thank you for a hundred
episodes
[Applause]
all right guys let's take a quick second
and hear from our Channel sponsor
identity theft in America is
skyrocketing U.S consumers reported
roughly 588 000 cases of identity theft
tied to credit cards auto loans and
other financing last year that's up a
shocking 155
000 cases compared to five years earlier
but you can help prevent your data being
stolen with a virtual Shield one virtual
Shield one monitors your accounts for
red flags from identity theft and is
backed up to one million dollars in
insurance coverage this all-in-one
Security Suite also comes with an
anonymous browsing with virtual Shields
no log military grade encrypted VPN one
privacy study showed 31 of respondents
experienced a data breach within the
last 18 months imagine the Peace of Mind
you'll have knowing virtual Shield one
is looking out for you virtual Shield is
available for Android and iOS mobile
devices as well as desktop and tablet
act now and get a free dark web scan and
67 off with a 60-day risk-free across
all of your devices by visiting
www.virtualshield.com perley that's
www.virtualshield.com pearly or simply
click the link in the description box
below find out why myself and hundreds
of thousands of users trust virtual
Shield one every day remember supporting
my sponsor help support the channel
thank you guys again okay so
um why don't we go around and have
everyone on the panel introduce
introduce yourself say your name your
age your relationship status where are
you from just a little bit about you
um why don't we start here okay hi
everyone my name is Brittany Renner I am
30 years old I'm single as a pringle I
have a one and a half year old son and
I'm here to learn something new today
I'll I'll help you with that
brought me
so they brought me here to look for
Trump she couldn't do it but she did it
here she is I am freshly 30. I am single
not ready to mingle yet and something
interesting about me well I'm a smart
woman I'm here to see if Mr take can
learn something from me oh
Sagittarius Sagittarius relax please be
nice be nice come on I wasn't rude
Andrew Tate 36 years old I cannot
disclose personal information because of
course my enemies are after me but uh
yeah I'm here to educate as I always am
perhaps somebody will say something
remotely insightful but uh at least I
get a clementine if not so I'm chilling
with Lauren
and it's your girl Esther the Nigerian
queen I'm here to entertain
to disagree with somebody in here
I'm just here to have a good time just
yeah get some Vibes and in terms of my
relationship relationship status I am
single
doing interviews I'm not just going for
anybody but yeah that's how it is
aren't you Jenny here 54. for me to cut
out the [__] simple
I like that okay I like that thank you
guys I bet you do yeah you have to cut
the [__] that's the problem with the
world today too much [__] and
they're not direct have they got
something to say to you just say it why
are you being mean already
give the girl a chance to speak now and
relax we'll go what have I said this one
what about saying
I don't believe in our elephants out
there something to say just say it don't
be around the bush if you've got
something to say to me I am here talk to
my face there should be no elephant in
the room because this ain't no Zoo you
understand so you've got something to
say just say it we'll be no I'm just
saying we're just all big people here so
if I want to say something to you I'm
going to say something to you straight
like I normally do ever got something to
say to Esther I'm going to tell Esther
whether she likes it oh no I don't
really care and you take my son's older
than him so I don't give a damn who he
is I'm gonna just tell you what I got to
say so whoever don't like it that's
tough don't come without Brittany I feel
picked on
okay so um right even Pearl too I feel
better now yeah
um Auntie was yelling at me and wife's
School the other day she doesn't give a
[__] um okay so my first question is
what is the number one problem facing
men today and what is the number one
problem facing women today I'm gonna say
something come on
the number one problem answer all the
questions come on top the number one
problem with men is that they don't tell
women the truth and a number one problem
with women that can't handle the truth
simple oh that that's a good that's a
good Paradigm to start from because it's
actually very interesting you say that a
lot of women say I just want a man who's
honest and then the second you're honest
she's like what you did wrong it's like
well then don't ask me for honesty of
course I [__] lie thank you so that's
a good that's a good point I agree with
that one I don't think it's the biggest
problem but it certainly is a problem in
relationships today that is a problem
the biggest problem with men today is
that I think the world is becoming hyper
competitive most men are not aware and
understanding of how quickly there's
going to be a genuine shift in between
those who have things and those who do
not have things not just finances but
also females status everything else and
it's a status game right and it's
becoming harder and harder for men to
play
and that's all women's fault of course
because no it is because women choose
the winners right women choose who the
high status males are so
women pretend to give a [__] about men
of course they don't they give a [__]
about themselves and and a woman and a
woman and a woman a woman if you ask her
what she wants from a man she's like I
don't want much I just want to find a
nice man who's a millionaire and six
foot tall and funny and charismatic and
interesting and spontaneous and looks
after me and doesn't cheat and and it's
funny and good looking and strong I
don't want much like they name all this
[__] that most dudes are never gonna
have and it's becoming harder and harder
and you end up with people
top G's who own everything on the planet
they could ever possibly wish for and
then you've got other guys who have
nothing and there's this large divide
there's no longer any Middle Ground you
have dudes who can't get any [__] and
then you've got dudes who are just
blocking girls off right and center and
that's what the problem with being a man
is today what about the women
Well everybody's got a chance to talk
shut up and have my Clementine no
no from you sir you want to learn from
me well I wanted to answer I feel like
it goes for both it's not just one of
the other I feel like it's
self-accountability
definitely women are not accountable for
themselves I agree with you there why
just women though
there is both you're right but Society
punishes men for not being
self-accountable but Society does not
punish women for not being
self-accountable I'll give you an
example if you're a man and you're
arrogant and you think you're something
when you're not trust me Society will
teach you very quickly that you don't
matter when you don't get laid and you
stay [__] broke if you're a chick and
think you're something when you're not
you can run around with your ego still
get dates still get laid still have a
fairly
sensible social life society as a whole
doesn't come along and slap you in the
face with realizations if you're a man
and you think you're something you're
not it is a ticking Time Bomb until
Society teaches you a lesson that's the
difference this is why men in general
are more self-accountable because the
men who are not self-accountable get
[__] up so those who are successful
are very self-accountable people they
look at themselves and go okay the only
way I'm going to get and progress
further the reason she left me the only
way I'm going to do better make more
money etc etc is I have to change most
women don't want to do that they don't
sit and think I have to change they
think oh he left me because it's him and
I lost my job because my boss and this
is this because of this no you know
women don't look in the mirror and
change a [__] thing no because don't
forget what you're forgetting right
nowadays they can't change it because
it's all about body positivity they can
look sexier in size 28. are you saying
lizzo's not a 10.
are you guys trying to get me canceled
see I'm not gonna
know what you just said because 90 of
cosmetic surgery is by women women are
trying to change as much as possible men
don't want to change they're not
accountable for themselves they think
that because because they're a man
you're going to be attracted to them no
like you can you can't be fat you stay
at home you're just playing video games
and you expect a woman to want to [__]
you no she's not going to want to [__]
you yeah but then she won't this is the
point and and and then she won't and
Society will teach them a lesson they
might be able to pull off a little blag
with a girl for a year or so but in
general they're gonna end up lonely in
general they're going to struggle to
find Partners I agree with you this with
the cosmetic surgery thing women are
happy to change out their appearance and
change how they look but they're not
happy to change how they act most of
them they're not happy to change them no
they're not the women are changing what
the men don't care about the men don't
care about the big old lips yes they do
no they do it the women are doing that
for themselves yeah because the men
don't care about it the men would rather
a woman change your stinking attitude
then put on all that makeup and hair and
everything that's what the men want but
the women I go out there like oh I'm
gonna change this I'm going to change
that if you look at a man and a man said
yeah he's fat the man almost if he's
feeling bad about himself he wants to
make that he'll go and hit the gym what
someone gonna do go and do it get a BBL
get her lips done put on her makeup put
on her hair and stay in a big old fat
person that she is and say oh it's body
positivity the men don't even want that
and then the women are not getting all
this cosmetic surgery for the men
they're getting it for themselves you
can't turn around what man wants a woman
that gonna turn around don't have an
operation they can't sit on a plane
because her ass has been injected or
been interfered with she's got a lie
there on her stomach you think the men
want that or wake up in the morning
before you gotta hit the house she's
gonna put on I'm sure I worried about
some of the men because they must go out
with a woman and then when they wake up
in the morning they think who the hell
is she the Sky by the time you take
everything off women need to change
their attitudes before they change their
makeup I'm sure that it even more than
that change your attitude because women
have got there and they would want to
change this they want to change that all
the things that don't count if you learn
to the same way how women can got that
lunch but make up learn to cook learn to
wash by hand learn to please
she's right for who I'm saying it's like
you're we had literally just talked
about this off camera when we when you
guys picking up from the airport when we
were talking about oh what are what's
the value system or the point system for
a woman who cooks versus a woman who can
suck good dick and [__] well but you
like cooking something because what I'm
saying is is that Pearl you can correct
me if I'm wrong but um quoting her was
that and when she interviewed people on
the street that there was more points
given to something for like a sexual
return as opposed to oh watch this is my
hand there's a dishwasher why cook we
can eat out there's a chef people don't
get they don't give a [__] about that
that's what they think but we literally
just talked about this yesterday no it
was okay I did a street interview and I
asked the guys would you rather have a
girl that gave good head or a good cook
in most guys they want this but I think
that's for the quick satisfaction I
think that's more for like a one night
stand but what I'm trying to say is that
if you all the women out there and
they're talking about well some of the
women want to be settled down they want
a man
right and you've got to think what the
man wants the man they're interested in
that look at when you when you're doing
Street interviews you're in during
single people
look at the people there that are
happily married and ask them what they
do because all the things that the women
out there doing you can be a housewife
you can be going out you can suck okay
just as good as any old [__] on the
street and keep your man and have a man
I'm not going to say that because I'm 32
years in counting Auntie you can't say
anything
you can't say attraction is not
important though it is important
initially exactly you a man is not not
gonna find you attractive and then think
oh because you you can cook well it's
got a chef a man's gonna find you
attractive and he's okay let's let's ask
Andrew
be with a girl that's five out of ten
because she can cook that ain't what I
said oh firstly that's not what she said
to be fair and the secondly I'd be with
a 10 out of 10 who can cook because I'm
top jeep but to make the point I think
what you have to understand is what men
are looking for in a relationship so you
did the the street interview and you're
asking single people probably young
people probably idiots you know they're
on camera talking [__] about good head
all this garbage [__] what men are
interested in in life not just in their
relationship but in their life as a
whole is status I don't think most
people understand especially women how
competitive the male world is and how
competitive it is for status this is why
men do everything they do men buy the
faster car not to drive any faster
because of status is why we want a
bigger house we don't give a [__] where
we live it's because of status that's
why I want to go to the gym and get big
and strong because of status everything
we do is about status it's why I want
the better jobs so I want more money
that's why I want to be respected so
what's the number one thing we want our
female to give us status that's what we
want so she can give us status by being
beautiful that's one thing she can do
but another thing she could do is if I
turn up home and I come home with my
boys and she says I'll cook you all a
steak that's status that's all my boys
going Ross you just been out all night
and she's here and she's going to cook
for all of us and she'll clean up and
tidy up boom that's the kind of girl a
man's not going to want to lose because
it makes him look good
status suck a dick blah blah blah listen
it can only be sucked in so many ways I
mean I know let's be serious about this
because you had the three thousand no no
no no this is actually a serious point
right this is a very serious point
because the Western world has collapsed
in real time and it's a failed Society
one of the reasons is a failed Society
is because of the over sexualization
especially of females as a whole if a
woman comes up to me and goes I'll be
the best sex you ever had I am [__]
revolted I don't want the best sex I've
ever had I want you to be pure and a
virgin you should know what sex is cook
my [__] dinner shut up don't come and
talk to me about [__] sucking dick
it's vile it's disgusting I don't want
to hear that [__] can I say something I
don't want to hear that [__] what I want
is a woman that makes me look good no
woman who's running around talking about
sucking dick can make me look good so I
lose interest completely and utterly and
that's the truth so what she's saying is
completely correct these are old school
things but it's not about the ACT yes
you can order food of course it's about
the status that comes with it that's
what it's about uh Sagittarius spoken
like a true one that is true
well my man so basically it's a straight
shooting sort of conversation but I
think that sometimes we get distracted
and we talk about the bigger because
between men and women I think that the
problem that men and women have have is
the consequences of the bad decisions
that the one percent of powerful men
make on our behalf because our problems
are on a societal level less than
between women and men that is why
there's a lot of competition between men
this Trace Force status that they will
never get men why is that the fault of
the one person a man because they're the
ones that drive the machine that runs
this the Western it's always been that
way yeah and but then think about the
Manda at the top now the corruption and
everything that's going on and this is
why it feels very good to sit next to
somebody like you and just say you know
what I appreciate that you say things
that are really true you expose a very
toxic truth and a very true truth as
well that is out there but the reality
is on the trenches when you go to the
Grassroots people don't feel the way
that you feel it's not as simple as what
you say they are victims of this system
so my job here is really not to try and
make about men and women is to make you
understand that actually we need to
start changing the narrative we want to
make it about men and women because
they're both messed up on either side
because then women look bad no because
it's about everybody together when women
have the traumas men have their traumas
I'm not here to fight against men and
women that's small I understand what
you're saying I understand what you're
saying but the idea the idea the idea
that this one percent of men have
created this terrible Society yeah I
talk about that I talk about the Matrix
I talk about these things but it's
always been this way it's always been a
small Elite group of men who are in
charge of the world and unfortunately
now we're fighting battles in different
ways the the days of old a man proved
his worth by going to war basically
every man at any point in his life was
going to end up going to war and he came
back Victorious he came back with honor
he got himself a wife that's that's how
it worked right now men don't have to go
to war as much depending on where you
live in the world and it's slightly
different and we fight our Wars in other
ways and one of the true expressions of
testosterone and trying to really
express your ability and your combative
ability now in the in the modern world
is power and influence so in the olden
days you go to war you come back with a
ribbon nowadays you got x amount of
followers you can move the world with
money I can bend reality with money
please understand if I walk into Jimmy
Choo they lock the door no broke he's
allowed in Tate's here and I buy
whatever the [__] I want there's lines
outside because I'm there I bend the
world with money that's how I that's how
the wars are now won so you're talking
about high status males and then it's
always been that way now you have a
whole contingent of men who aren't dead
okay they didn't die in a ditch but the
loneliest [__] jerking off and that's
the reality of it and and women don't
give a [__] about them and why should
you I'm not sitting here actually
[__] on women in any way I think
women have a biological instinct to a
degree to try and find the best mate
they can because it gives them the
highest chance of survival and the harsh
realities of the world and if they look
at a man who's not capable they just
don't feel an attraction to him and
that's the bottom line of it and that's
why I actually most I'm largely
misunderstood I don't blame women for a
lot of the problems women are guilty of
certain things but I have a massive
amount of blame to place on men because
there's so many men who are genuinely
incompetent I was a chick I wouldn't
[__] these losers either like they're
losers so it's hard to balance I love it
you know what I understand why people
always go for the one percent all the
women one word for the one percent why
don't you just find a regular nine to
five person that's gonna look after you
you can be his Queen why can't you just
do that why is it
32 years happy as Larry what is the
problem Oh the old-fashioned it can it
works no Auntie let me clarify when I
meant one percent is not the one percent
of Attraction I mean the actual people
that are in charge of the things that
run the world the way that what I'm
trying to say is that it's always been
an umbrella we've lived under but the
different functioned underneath it so
why is it going to affect me I'll
explain why because as Sir Mr Andrew
King Tate said
what she's after I'll have this one
after this afternoon
it is I've been drinking lime juice as
well so as he very rightly said Society
has now evolved before men went to war
now men don't go to war so there's a lot
of sense of no purpose that they need to
find and then on the women's side is
that the same way that a society evolved
and made men feel less purpose they have
now had to take on bigger purposes they
have to go to work like they didn't have
to do before they have to take care of
the family and work and do all of these
things and now deal with the fact that
men are feeling a little bit like out of
you know the rubbish say what I'm saying
you're getting that you get a nine to
five person right what is wrong with you
going out there find a regular
nine-to-five person right you can
function underneath that because I'm
always saying the women say oh we ain't
got enough money we ain't got enough
money work with what the man's got
you're right work with what the man's
got you can make Emmanuel Alpha
everybody wants to go and find these top
earning money find a nine to five work
regular save your money learn to cook
and not have takeouts and then save your
money as I did before then you should
direct this to the men that feel upset
because they're not like coming to the
man she's completely completely be right
I'll give you I'll tell you this there's
not a girl on this panel or on the
planet today who couldn't walk outside
and find a man who's gonna be nice to
her loyal to her and make her his Queen
women don't want that so they'll sit
there and go no I want Chris Brown and
then they'll go try to get Chris Brown
then Chris Brown will cheat and they'll
be like I can't believe he cheated I am
devastated what the [__] do you think is
gonna happen if I go to the car garage
right you have to make a decision what
you truly want in your life if you truly
want to just find a manager and look
after you and take care of you you're
going to be his Queen he's going to be
loyal you can find that all day but
you're going to have to settle to a
degree where a lot of women perhaps are
not prepared to do that you see the you
see how women act they'd rather chase a
fraction of a real G's time than have a
hundred percent of the time of a [__]
dude who they don't they don't respect
at that level and it's kind of going to
a car dealership you walk in there you
if you want reliability you can get in
this sand but if you want to get a
Ferrari it comes with it comes with
headaches it's going to come with
problems so when girls say to me oh you
know what Andrew you know you should be
loyal to the men like me don't have to
be and you know that so why the [__] are
you here trying to tell me what to do
because you know I don't have to be
loyal and all the girls I'm [__]
don't have to be loyal so why are you
sitting there pretending you expected me
to be loyal when everyone knew from
ground up day one it was never going to
ever [__] happen and you're still
here I think you're still texting
they're gonna be the one that changes
you oh no yeah
is the female decision they sit there
and decide no I want this this this this
this this cool then you're gonna have to
accept it ain't gonna be loyal to you
he's barely going to reply to you that's
the game
I swear to God this show has made me
believe I think women like to be cheated
on I don't I swear to God no because all
you'll ever talk about is your exes that
cheated on you that's all you'll ever
talk about and it's like it's like I
always talks about that the regular
women around here the women oh good
thing I'm a regular and extraordinaire
but do you not think it's because we're
not holding men accountable so when I'm
mad because he's a top J cheats on a
woman it's like well what do you expect
when you should actually turn around
I'm countable okay accountable for its
natural evolutionary biology it's
cheating morally correct yes it depends
yes
okay with your woman cheating on you
then absolutely not that's all right now
because oh it's a rap machine it cheats
on you but you can cheat on her there
has not been in the history of humanity
across any culture any book any story
any Fable there has never been across
the history of humanity any respect put
on the name of a promiscuous female ever
ever you name the biggest conquerors
that you can possibly name from history
Genghis Khan Alexander the Great all of
them they all had 100 wives bunch of
children Big G conquered the world
normal that is normal evolutionary
biology that's how men are designed to
be there's never been a single female
who's been celebrated for a promiscuity
ever in history it's always been frowned
upon and disgusting so yes we are
completely and utterly different yes
it's different if a woman cheats on a
man and if a man is at a complete top
level of his life and ticks every single
box and if he decides to be loyal which
some do and I can be loyal and I have
been loyal but there's also times in my
life where I think [__] it I don't want
to be and get a new girlfriend every
single day of the week I can do that and
I can decide to do that if a woman
decides to do the same purely because
her value is high enough to attract so
many males because she's beautiful for
example it is completely different and
I'm gonna explain to you why it's
completely different so buckle up it's
different
different it's different well I'll tell
you why but it's impossible for a female
to be promiscuous on a long enough
period of time without devaluing herself
because she is [__] people she
shouldn't be [__] there is no way she
is sleeping with endless men and all of
them are either high value men or
treating her the way she should be
treated if you find a woman who slept
with 50 100 dudes she's either [__]
dudes which are at her level or haven't
worked hard enough to try and get the
[__] she was just too drunk to realize
he's a loser who plays video games or
she's [__] a top geek who barely
texts her back so either way she's
[__] dude she shouldn't be [__] or
a guy who's at the level who doesn't
give her the right amount of attention
for a woman to find a guy who's truly on
a level who truly treats her the way she
should be treated that's once every
couple years if that you ain't just
gonna go out there [__] a new dude
every week and say yeah he's worth [__]
yeah he treats me good enough to get my
[__] and you know what's funny about
the universe it's actually beautiful
about the universe because it's equal
and opposite forces when you devour
yourself it's kind of like men can smell
it on you they can just look at a [__]
and go oh and that's the way it works so
you have to be very careful the female
and sit and go does this man truly
deserve to [__] me if you think about it
the answer 99 of the time especially if
you're promiscuous is no so when a woman
is sleeping around with all these men
she's devaluating herself she's
devaluing herself and the world knows
God knows the universe knows when a man
does it he doesn't devalue himself at
all that's just the way it works can I
ask you a question wait wait wait wait
and so one second son may I ask you a
question what would you say if a woman
now is married to two men
no I'll tell you why let's talk about
this what is the difference between a
man let's say me I have four wives right
what's the difference between a man
having four wives and a woman having
four men you can impregnate the four
wives at the same time you're gonna
pregnant the four wives at the same time
and we know who the parents are right so
let's say you had four pregnancies you'd
know who the mother is because she's
carrying the baby and you know who the
dad is top G if you had a woman with
four men and she gets pregnant who's the
who's the parents what about if I'm
asking okay I ask what if they're
different races
now modern science can come along and
maybe fix that for you but that doesn't
mean it's not wrong in the eyes of God
the idea of having a family the idea of
a child being born one of the baselines
for a new life to come onto this planet
is for at least to understand who the
two people who made it are at least if
you have a woman [__] four Dudes you
don't even know who's who who are
pregnant
wait wait have you seen the twins that
had two different dads oh oh yeah I saw
that may I just say something then so if
that is the case yeah if the one thing
that you're meant to Hobbies you at
least you know who the two people that
put that child on Earth are then that's
why promiscuity for men is also a
problem because they get women pregnant
sometimes they don't even know they have
children that's around no no it's
completely different it's different
because you have to understand I'm
talking about humans you look at humans
from a societal perspective but Society
has changed right so let's say two three
hundred years ago if a woman got
pregnant she needed a man to survive if
that man didn't take care of her during
pregnancy she was going to die she
couldn't work a job she couldn't hunt
couldn't fish whatever right a woman
literally needed that man for survival
so if if you were to come to me and say
I'm pregnant but you've been [__] by
four different dudes I'm like who says
it's mine why am I looking after you
none of everyone look after her she will
literally perish this is why in most of
the world today still today Virginia is
so coveted and throughout all of history
it's been so coveted because that's the
only way to ensure paternity she's a
virgin I know that's my baby she a
virgin prove it's mine outside of this
modern science [__] shaytan the
devil we have here in the west and most
of the world today was without virginity
or at least a low body count or at least
uh anti-promiscuity you can't tell that
that's your baby so it's a completely
different thing you're looking at the
idea of a man a woman being pregnant and
coming to a group of men and saying one
of you has to take care of me and put up
with me when I'm fat and Moody and
annoying and I need my bills paid and
all the men are gonna sit there and go
no [__] no prove it's mine you can't
prove it bounce where it's different if
I get four women pregnant we know that
we know the deal okay so let me ask you
a question so obviously back then for
Survivor women needed a man otherwise
when they were pregnant could die and
all of these things they would perish in
today's society given Evolution given
the fact that as women we can go
together yeah but I'm I'm not saying
that isn't there a glitch between what
is actually happening and the nature of
what we have in our bodies I think
that's probably the conflict that we're
having right now glitch in what way in
the sense that women don't feel like
they need men in the most physical sense
perhaps like naturally it's very
interesting women don't feel like they
need men in a physical sense because
life is soft but it's but it's but it's
[__] and it's [__] because you
still need Men by proxy one and two the
second life gets difficult you very
quickly you very quickly learn how much
you need men but women don't go I'm
independent I don't need no man because
I have an only fans and Men be my only
fans and if anyone comes up to me I'll
call a male police officer I don't need
men shut up [__] idiot of course you
do you just named your whole life is
based on [__] men the roads are
driving along was paved by a man the
house you're living in was built by a
man the car you're driving who was
designed by a man your whole life
depends on men and the second anything
bad were to happen to you the second you
were physically threatened or times were
to get hard or War were to start or
famine or riots the first thing you do
is find a big strong man [__] yourself
and throw the feminism out the window
feminism goes out the [__] window the
second that the snow needs shoveling or
there's a [__] broken down car or the
tire needs changing then all that crap
vanishes it's garbage and this is the
actual very interesting thing I'll make
a point here which is gonna be canceled
again but I don't give a [__] but but
this is the point feminism in and of
itself can't be defended any idea the
point of an idea is that it could be
defended by the people who believe in it
this is what the whole point of War
since the dawn of time it doesn't matter
if it's the Christians against the
Hindus it doesn't matter if it was the
Germans against the French there were
people who had ideas and ideology these
and they're prepared to fight each other
to defend their ideology feminism is an
ideology which cannot be defended by
feminists the only people could
defeminism are The Men Who
Ryan say we want feminism and the
conservative men were to get in a line
you will learn very quickly it's
[__] I had a friend in Afghanistan
when Taliban kicked America out and he
told me
the Americans were telling were telling
the girls that could go to school so
they built all these girls schools and
they put the afghanistani Defense Forces
there and they'd get funded the
Afghanistan forces to to protect these
schools you had American satellites you
had night vision goggles Taliban were
afraid to attack America leaves now you
have Afghani Defense Forces they're
basically blind they don't have
satellites anymore that don't have a
night vision whatever so now it's a real
war
the manner standing next to this girl's
school the Taliban are coming you're
some dude you're standing there and
you're looking at this girl's school
going
I don't really give a [__] if girls go
to school bounce and you just and you
didn't fight so that's why they all gave
up and Taliban took over so quickly and
when I said this to girls like yeah they
should have fought for us feminism to
why don't the women fight can I ask oh
wait the women can't defend their own
[__] idea you need men to defend
feminism so that's why the whole thing
is stupid so second men don't defend it
it does it just fails it's a [__]
ideology it's garbage may I tell you
something now so this is the thing this
is when we assume that women perhaps
don't have the physical or even mental
ability to go to school wait wait
because this is the thing for example in
Ukraine a lot of women took up arms and
in fact I'm on Golden wait wait I'm
angolan wait wait I'm angolan listen
people at home wait no worries I'll talk
about my person
wait let me tell you let me tell you
something this is the thing I think it's
also really like silly to assume that
for example woman because she didn't go
to school she'll not be as intelligent
as a man therefore naturally a woman is
not intelligent no it doesn't make sense
if we're now starting to normalize
equality and we want to put everybody in
the Forefront give a woman a normalizing
equality well that's what what people
are wanting then that's okay let me tell
you I want to normalize the quality
people like oh feminists well actually
no equality I want respect that's really
yeah I'm stopping you from getting
respects no I get respect I get respect
I get respected
what I think is you never know what you
want I'll tell you what I don't know
what you want you're right as a woman I
carry myself differently I actually hold
the things I have done in the fight side
for I hold it that's why when you speak
to me I don't move different I move
different to many of the girls that's
why when you talk to men you argue with
me I don't take it you do sometimes and
I'll tell you something a lot of women
may have the accolades to be somebody
but they are uncomfortable to own that
and the reason why then I would like to
ask you for example
um I do need a man for example to you
know procreate but other than that I'm
quite strong and I would find things
that I would find a way to protect
myself differently with that mentality
what would be the man that would be for
me then another what would you do if one
of these security guards broke into your
door
[Laughter]
okay they see you're not dead it's okay
no I'll be like this and then if not
maybe I'll kind of like be very gentle
and comply to find a way to get out okay
so if they want to come and kill me well
let's make it there's not much that many
people can make an important Point
you're talking about a quality equaling
respect the way you get respect as a
woman is by being feminine there's
nothing we can be equal and very very
different I'm not saying that where
there's not equality but you've confused
equality with the same you can be equal
with completely different things you can
have a bishop and a knight on a
chessboard they're equal in terms of
points but they do different things
right a woman can have equal respect to
a man if she is very good at being a
woman and a man gets respect for being
very good at being a man when a woman
decides she wants to act like a man or a
man wants act like a woman that's where
all gets [__] up we're trying to
pretend it's all the same it's not the
same men and women are good at different
things we have different strengths
different weaknesses there's nothing
wrong with accepting that there's
nothing wrong with saying I'm a woman
I'm good at X he's a man who's good at
why then we work together as a team we
have a beautiful family we're happy
forever it's only confused where you
have women who sit and go no because in
the name of equality we can fight and
work there's no [__] women on the
front line in Ukraine that is silent
[__] they put some chick there
dancing around doing Pokemon dancers to
try and convince men to go [__] die
in a ditch it's garbage if you go to the
front line of Ukraine right now you do
not see women in their makeup and their
manicures you see [__] men in the
freezing cold dying you know where the
women are Dubai chilling that's where
the women are so to sit and pretend that
women are just as capable physically as
men as a [__] lies delusion
descending your strongest man is
delusion you are good at other things
you're better than men at a lot of
things but it's not the physical world
and the unfortunate reality about life
this is what we're saying when I was
saying earlier that feminism goes out
the window when things get hard the
harder the world gets it the closer it
gets to the Baseline of humanity the
unfortunate Baseline of humanity is
violence that's what happens when if of
all the elect electricity were to go out
and all the police were to quit this
would become a violent place very
quickly and there would be [__] zero
feminists left zero you would all need
men that's the bottom line of reality
that's the bottom line so you have to
understand as a woman to say okay but I
need a man who's good at being a man but
no one's saying that we don't need men
in society of course we do we're talking
about relationships yeah you're strong
but the thing is I can live my life as a
woman and not need a man what's a woman
[Laughter]
yes we need men in society but in
relationship the only reason I actually
need you is because I want you I don't
actually need you
I need you I need you to procreate yes I
agree but the things I don't need you in
my day-to-day life but wait wait what if
someone breaks into your house I'll just
call that okay what if they don't come
what if the average in the US it takes
like 50. in the fifth in the U.S it
takes like 15. that is for them to get
that's not realistic okay
these two guys in your in your house
what are you doing that's no no mistake
I've not had any man break into my house
on a day today
I know what you're saying but the point
is this the point is
when we're talking about feminism as a
whole feminism as a whole demonizes men
and you just said you just sat and said
besides procreation I don't need a man
in my life I can go to a male mechanic
or call a male police officer they're
men so it's it
I agree I agree of course we need you of
course so you're talking about being
with a man because you want to so my
question to you is why would you want to
be with them why would a man want to be
with you because they're sexy like
obviously
I like it but it's not all about Dick
what I'm trying to say is no in a good
relationship right one that works
there's Blue Jobs and there's pink jobs
right and that's the problem that women
have got oh geez they don't want to be
doing no pink jobs but that's not what I
mean
we're talking
about in a relationship
partner which companionship friendship
romantic love things that you can't get
by yourself technically you want to go
on dates with him it's not about I need
someone to fix my car like go to a
mechanic You're Not Safe call the police
what about a father to your kids you
don't think you're excited you can be
around I definitely want that these are
the stuff this is the reason
I agree wait wait wait it's not it's not
that you want it you need it I agree and
these are the stuff that I need in a man
but it's like at the end of the day it's
not like I completely need you I want
the whole but the whole point is if the
lights went out tomorrow you would need
a man
like women useless
I'm saying if if the lights went out
tomorrow you would need someone to
protect you you will of course in a
society not my boyfriend half of my exes
can't even do anything that's actually
another problem a lot of men can't do
much you know what I mean not everybody
in this day and age guys can't even fit
a tired
I have to do one at a time can I just
say something this is why you can't
blame all men for your poor choices
you can't say I'm talking to both of you
because you are saying yeah my mind
can't do this my man can't do that what
and you want to settle down why would
you go and choose a man
that can't do these things that you
wanted them to do because my man could
do all the blue I need a man because
most men grow up with a PlayStation
instead most men grow up with
PlayStations
no that's the truth speak for yourself
speak for yourself
my boyfriend you know what I need a
father to my children I don't need
something right she needs a police
officer she needs a farmer for her
children right so she's gonna go out
there right and you're going to buy your
child an electric car you're gonna go
and buy your child a bicycle Who the
hell's gonna play the bicycle and fix
the electric car who doesn't do it
you've got YouTube I know how to do
these things
yourself go and get some sperm done or
something because you obviously don't
need a man that's the future the future
for who no of course
yes
let me finish talking right now you go
you got a man right and you've been busy
all day right and you're in your bed at
one o'clock in the morning and your man
comes in with all of his friends
and said oh babes all the friends are
here they're hungry what you're gonna do
yeah I'll cook for my man I
I'm okay
National it's everything it's not just
about cooking everything
I have a question are you virgin you're
traditionally a virgin are you a virgin
in that aspect I'm not gonna comment on
me being a virgin or not but what I'm
gonna say is every every human being
should be able to cook
tradition and modernization that
survives you know I need to cook to
survive can I can I ask me to take
something right I'm gonna ask you
something sure right because I I can't I
don't like [__] right and like
there's not some people that I can't
I'm going to talk to him because so far
he's talking sense thank you very much
thank you just give him pick me right
who said pick me
they want me to
me
I got a minute I've been with my man for
32 years
32 years I don't need to clap for myself
because I'm happy I'm not here and what
I was gonna ask him right is how would
you think a woman would you think that
woman would you think that woman who's
calm down I'm I'm loud I'm not you don't
want to hear me shout anyway Mr
technical saying before we got really
interrupted right now if you is this
your idea of a woman that you think
deserves a man
I'm here
single but I'm looking
I'm here I'm like taking you if you want
to hook me up let me know and I just
want any of anybody but choose how does
that make you feel well is that kind of
woman that you think deserves a man well
he's a top G you can't be asking him
this question
we're me Immortals and see for yourself
we have options
you said unlike you I have options we
have options yeah you're out here
looking for a man you're out here saying
that you're looking yeah well that's
what I was looking for men oh my gosh
she was at the advertising when we done
the introductions
I didn't say I was going out looking for
a minute
decide if I want you Mr Tate listen to
this insult right listen to the outside
listen in Sign Language what I'm
learning sign language listen to what
she just said to me unlike you I have
options [__] 32 years you think I
want options
though because
I'm sure you didn't mean pick me you
meant clout Chaser is that what it is
trying to clarify your problems
why would I want to have options when
I've been in a happy relationship for
30. no Cloud chases his fans
you can monetize on YouTube with clout
why are you calling her a pygmy when
you're the one advertising at the
beginning of the show I said I'm doing
interviews I wasn't advertising nothing
wait wait wait wait wait understand what
an interview means okay she's being
spicy guys stop it Auntie had a question
for Andrew oh yeah what was your
question oh she asked already he didn't
answer because everybody was too busy
jumping in already up but he's not too
busy jumping in and being women
so he's ready to get married you know
shut up and let him answer in it I'll
answer yeah so so to go back to one of
my earlier points firstly to make it
clear in the disagreement I agree with
of course I think everyone knows who I
agree with but um I do because you know
what it is though you know what's
actually funny
the things that she's saying are common
knowledge 20 30 years ago this is how
the world functioned this is how the
whole world functioned the things I say
that somehow people believe are
controversial are exactly the way the
world functioned in like the 90s the AES
to 70s all of the entire period of human
history men had a role of masculinity
women had a role of femininity we worked
as a team now the world's come along and
they've destroyed and broken everything
and there's this new Progressive think
and this new generation of women who
seem to believe that if we completely
[__] it all up it's going to end up
better and my argument to that is listen
we went from walking around in fields in
small nomadic groups to building cities
to building the pyramids to going to the
Moon we managed to go from a few
thousand to billions of people populate
the entire planet build canals build
skyscrapers cities all of this was done
based on the back of man being a man
woman being a woman working together as
a family and I was destroyed now they're
gonna come along and [__] it up if it's
not broken it's destroyed it's been
destroyed man has destroyed Earth what
are you talking about it's been bad
decisions from powerful men that got men
to go to Wars and from women to lose
husbands men built men make decisions
for war men kill men please listen to me
men built the Earth I'm not saying men
are perfect but the entire world that
you're existing under was built by man
yes so so and the point I'm making is
now we're entering a world of new think
and that the problem with new think is
it's not tested I don't give a [__] what
anyone's opinion is what I can State as
a matter of fact is we had 5 000 years
of history that tells us how the world
works with X and Y together we're now
entering a new paradigm There's No 5 000
years of History so whatever you believe
about how it's going to work or it's
going to be better or worse whatever
that's just you guessing everyone is
guessing right so renting a brand new
paradigm and everything's completely
[__] up the point you were making
earlier which is a fantastic one about
if I'd pick a woman who's advertising
Etc et cetera men always please keep
this in mind if you're especially if
you're a female people always say you
know the number of emails I get from
girls who say you don't give enough girl
games I'll give you a girl game right
now your man wants status that's what he
wants you need to find a way to make him
look good to the world and to his
friends so how do you do that I'll tell
you one of the ways a man can get status
is to get the girl that no one can get
that's a very simple way right so I said
not ready to mingle I did right okay no
no but this is the truth right if you if
I date a girl
and she's perfect in every way head to
toe and then I'd say I've met this girl
yes she's this she's this oh yeah I took
her for a date even if you didn't [__]
her if you [__] her no no just went for
a date so you went the attraction goes
from this to zero done and it may not
for some men because some men haven't
got choices but men like me who
genuinely have unlimited options we want
complete exclusivity that's what we're
looking for because that gives status
that's what you're looking for so you
have to be very careful as a female with
all of your actions all of your
interactions with your boyfriend or when
you're looking for a boyfriend Etc and
say am I gonna make my man look better
by doing X or look worse simple things
I've had endless arguments about girls
nights out right oh you're insecure it's
not about insecure I don't give a [__]
if no man talks to you all night long I
don't care if you're going out and
you're going to an all-girl Club I don't
care I know that when my boys say oh all
the girls are going out and I say not my
girl she stays home I look good that's
it she stays home she doesn't go out she
doesn't want she doesn't want to go out
without me that status it's not about
the night out it's about the status of
being the man in the house that's what a
man wants he wants respect he wants to
be the man of the house I say she stays
home she stays home Big G boom boom
that's what we want can I ask you
something what about what does the the
woman want in your eyes what do you
thinking what's the game you get for the
boys I'm gonna tell you but before that
I need another Clementine and I need to
give half to our friend here because she
just rolled her eyes at me and I'm
perspicacious I know it's everything she
doesn't realize that I'm a ninja I
detect these things even when I'm
looking directly here I can detect it
I'm gonna give her some of my Clementine
and she's gonna feel better so I'm gonna
get Clementine for you would you like
some Clementine I'm sure I just I think
for me it's like I asked you a question
yeah I would love something you want
some Clementine yeah we're gonna hook it
up okay Clementine's coming all right go
on continue okay well no I mean I just
feel like this is definitely a different
conversation for me because I I'm very
open-minded I love hearing different
perspective and I do feel like
um this is a newer idea like like you
said within the last 30 40 years this is
a New Concept we don't know how it's
going to end I just know from from like
my experience other women that I've met
as well it's like the reason for even
like relationships why they're not
lasting is because people don't want to
put up with a disrespect and like even
when you were talking about like oh it's
okay for me to cheat but not for you my
thing is is like why not have
transparency and have it be polygamous
polyamorous whatever works for you
that's like to me where it loses me with
the traditional stuff it's like why
can't we have transparency if I sign up
for that cool so how does it no okay no
no man no man in a millionaire let's all
be realistic right no man and
Millionaire's gonna meet a girl who
likes and go I want to be polyamorous
like come on let's gay let's cut this
[__] so let's let's be realistic how
does a man show love to a woman
exclusivity wrong time resources and
something else time resources so yeah
that's a good that's a good way to start
so sexual exclusivity is how female
shows primarily primarily that she's
interested in a man he's the only man
who has sexual access to me because I
can get pregnant and this man is the
only man who can do it that's how it's
done a man yes I'm not saying all men
can cheat I'm not saying all men should
cheat I'm not saying that I'm saying
that if I truly love a woman she won't
sit there and go he shows me his love
because he doesn't [__] anyone else
she'll sit there and go he shows me his
love because my bills are paid I'm in a
Bentley I drive like private I go to
Dubai anytime I want I have a Chanel bag
and I'm not talking about just money I'm
talking about resource and a lifestyle
as a whole this is not just me this is
the world and most of the world today if
you go to Moscow and you find a big g a
rich guy right he has his wife she's
pushing a Bentley she's the kid she's
living in a mansion whatever when he
goes to the club with his boys you think
he ain't with 19 year old strippers of
course he [__] is she's just like
whatever don't care I'm the one who has
the money don't give a [__] so you have
to sit there and to a point you have to
sit and analyze the the difference when
you're saying disrespect if you're gonna
if you're gonna go through life as a
woman and say I only care about the
sexual exclusivity of my man then what
you're going to end up doing is having a
bunch of failed relationships and
[__] loads of dudes there has to get
a point where you go you know what this
guy takes so many boxes once a year
twice a year he's out with his boys does
some dumb [__] I'm just gonna pretend I
didn't notice because my bills are paid
I'm looked after I can tell he cares
about me if I have a problem he's gonna
fix it he's kicked somebody that's the
smart female move as opposed to go I
don't care how good he is to me he
[__] that [__] once so I'm gonna
leave and I'm gonna get another man who
I don't love who'll [__] another [__]
anyway and then I'll get another man who
and the cycle of dumb [__]
I have a question is there ever cheating
that's too far like so if a guy cheats
on a girl is there ever a point where
she yeah there's a lot of cheating
there's completely a lot of cheats like
if he if he knocks up another girl all
right all right so first things first
I'm a man of my word I don't even think
I'm a liar
so here's your Clementine
thank you and he peeled it well thank
you I'm a gentleman right so obviously
I'm not saying blatantly disrespect your
woman right she's your woman she's your
queen she's the most important thing in
the world to you she needs to be
retreated in a way that she feels that
right but it's unfortunate because I
keep tying back to this Baseline point
but the reason I keep going back to this
Baseline point is to try and explain to
everybody at home how simple the world
can be if you go back to the baselines
of it why do men cheat most women don't
know you'll see them all the time why do
men cheat all because manage is stupid
and why do men [__] girls uglier than
their main chick why do men do all this
stuff you know why I'll tell you why
let's go back to the first thing I've
been saying this whole time status yeah
that's my chick she's home took this one
home yeah I got that one she's chasing
me status status but it's but it's
stupid to females I get it but that's
the male world because sexual access is
an easy indicator of status so that's
one of the reasons they do it right so
you have to go back into the Baseline of
white men even cheat in the first place
I'm telling you if you're a woman the
smartest thing you can do is look after
your man make him not want to cheat be
perfect but there's going to be a time
across a 20-year marriage you might just
need to be a little bit blind a little
bit just a tiny bit just don't look at
his phone so and you'll be cool you'll
be cool just make sure the bills are
paid he does his job well if you can pay
your own bills but this is it we'll talk
about that in a second but I'm not
saying allow this for some [__] Joe
schmoe I'm not saying let some [__]
loser pick you up lock you down and go
shoot right I'm not saying that I'm
saying if he's a gene he's doing enough
of his other jobs as for you saying what
if you can pay your own bills then then
what's the reality you face just like I
described earlier I am going to decide
that the thing that I prioritize above
everything above his resource above the
amount he cares for me you'll see men
cheat on a woman and then cry his eyes
out trying to get that woman back he
still loves you it's not the same as if
you cheated he loves you with all his
heart he'd Die For You he'd take a
bullet for you and he still [__] that
[__] doesn't matter it's a different
game for men right so you're sitting
here going well I don't I'm going to
prioritize his sexual exclusivity over
all of his other Cal all of his other
attributes you're just gonna end up
having endless failed relationships
[__] too many dudes and then what's
gonna happen is your psychology is going
to break because females don't like to
accept the fact that if you sleep with
enough men and you get rid of the stigma
around a new dick your instant answer is
constantly new dick I didn't text me
today [__] it someone else ah he was
rude to me [__] I'll cheat ah he was
this I was getting a new boyfriend and
then you end up just jumping on [__] all
day and you're [__] done you need to
that the reality is there has to come a
point where you
expect boxes you're like you know what
I'm wifey I got the Bentley he does
whatever he does but my bills are paid
when when would you say right now when
would you say it's too far
I'm just curious if there's a line that
you would like if he spends money on
another girl if he like when does it
okay that's a good question another
second question do you think that men
ever fall in love with side chicks very
good question and this is a long and
in-depth answer but it's a good question
let me peel my Clementine but um no but
it's a good question where it's too far
I think publicly disrespecting is too
far
so like you'll you'll notice let's talk
to Moscow G all right let's take an
oligar a billionaire from Moscow he has
his wife he has the girls he's in the
club with the girls he's in the club
with wouldn't [__] dare message his
wife they wouldn't dare step out of line
like they know their place right so if
there's a hierarchy and they know their
place that's one way of doing it
spending money on a girl certainly yeah
because men show love primarily through
our through our hard work not just
through our resource but through our
hard work if you take a man who's not
particularly Rich he shows his wife love
by getting up every day going to work
nine to five working his ass off and
paying those bills that's how he shows
love that's why he does it for his wife
and his children most men around here
working [__] jobs carrying trash
they're doing that to show love so
giving money yeah that would be a far
more scary indicator than just sex let
me give you all an example I don't know
if you all know my history but I used to
run a webcam business a long time ago
don't talk about it blah blah but I had
a bunch of girls who used to sit online
and talk to guys and they had laptops
right this is a long time ago and I used
to sit and say to some of the webcam
girls I'd say
this man who is sitting in and logging
in every night and sending you money
every day and telling you he's obsessed
with you from the other side of the
world and missing out on time with his
family to sit here and talk to you and
send you money that is more cheating
than if he just went out and banged
something if he went out and banged
something and came home then done but
he's sitting here giving you his time
his money his affection that's cheating
for a man for a man to sit there and
give money and time away right so you
have to stop this idea of sexual
exclusivity yes that's for females
that's how females show their love to
men it's not how high status at least
males show their love to females and and
anyone who wants to disagree me call me
wrong call me misogynist whatever
[__] look at a history book every
King every Sultan every conqueror every
Emperor every night all of them all of
them had maidens wives all of them
that's history what level of G do you
have to be to be allowed to cheat it's
not about even being allowed to cheat
I'm not even saying that and it also
depends on the partner you're with I'm
not trying to sit here and advocate for
men to run around and [__] a bunch of
women I'm not saying that no but I'm not
no no
what I'm actually trying to do is
describe the Baseline unfortunate
realities of human dynamics and I'm
trying to explain now to the world that
any woman can get a man who will not
cheat on her if she's prepared to
sacrifice a bunch of other things
perhaps right in the olden days it was
different the world was a different
place it was a completely different
place and it was better now it's all
[__] up it's [__] up on every level
and Men especially the high status men
most of them have struggled so hard to
become High status they've been through
so much [__] to get where they are it's
like telling him if you climb this
mountain you can go to a candy store and
he climbs to the top of the mountain and
the second he's in the candy store after
one piece of candy that [__] is saying
no no more candy he's like no I just
climbed this mountain I just got rich I
just went through XYZ I finally got here
I'm finally the candy store now you're
telling me I can only have one piece of
candy okay
do you think do you think that men owe a
woman royalty if she was there from the
beginning absolutely they absolutely owe
that woman loyal I'm sorry sexual
loyalty that's what I meant sexual
sexual exclusivity is different ma'am
sorry I mean
sexual exclusivity and loyalty are
completely disconnected for males nobody
wants to talk about this but it's the
unfortunate reality is true I'm telling
you you can get a man he can go on a
holiday you can [__] some stripper could
come home and you can lie detect or test
him do you love your wife would you die
for your wife would you take a bullet
for your wife that he'll pass the lie
detector test he loves her with all his
heart do anything for her
I feel like I guess my question would be
then is like how do you view sex because
I I like sex at the end of the day is
spiritual unification I feel like I've
gone through a lot of different stuff
I've had a lot of different experiences
where I did not value myself so I never
had a man that valued me so it's like
yeah you rack up guys and guys you
shouldn't be texting back or whatever
but I feel like they're I understand
that there is a difference with how men
view sex and how they move around in the
world but it's like sex is a sacred
thing no matter male or female is doing
it so that's why for me like my biggest
like the hardest for me to understand is
like this is such a a sacred thing and
it's just being it's like taking a piss
for a guy can I just say something are
you sure making love to somebody about
having sex
I'm sorry you were sure that you were
making love to somebody with that was
just having sex
in there no that's what it sounds like
to me it sounds like as women they make
love to men that are just having sex
right
that's the difference that's not the
point but my thing is okay so I think
when men hear that though it's like if
it was sacred to you you would have
waited till you were married but it's
like right no I get I get that but the
the reality is is that the world is not
so black and white so I understand that
there are these things in place that
worked and made sense and now we're
approaching an era that like we don't
know what's gonna happen but there's
gray area you've had sex I've had sex
she's had sex we've had sex with
different guys that doesn't mean that
we're damaged goods we're used Goods I
understand status is a big part of that
I understand that sex is view
differently but I feel like you should
not if you're if you're looking at face
value I can understand why you would be
judged from your past but if if I'm a
guy interested in you I don't care about
what you've done
like men do though that's the thing like
like a virgin's more valuable to a man
than a girl that's had sex with multiple
men like it just is what it is but the
modern man is not a virgin a modern man
needs a partner somebody that's actually
some smart and surviving
are going to pick women that are more
pure in general the ones that already
self-made I guess so but that's the
thing the reality is the reality is that
there's a lot of men out there
especially in the world that we live in
today that need a partner so it's time
for those masses of men to start
respecting women for the role they can
play in their lives I don't think I
don't think average men expect women
but is this rhetoric that actually then
is pumped into these mines and creates
what people not complain about the
misogynistic world that's what it is
Independent Schools is
prefer women that are more it's not that
it's but it's not that's not the problem
the problem is now listen the maths is
very simple you've got people like
Andrew Tate talking about these things
with such Clarity and it makes so much
sense because it is true right and then
you have men that are in these
situations where just average working an
average job and they cannot fulfill
whatever definition is called to be a
man in these yes they can and that's
what they said he didn't say that yes
they can nine to five men can do it but
then again but wait wait this is the
thing what we're talking about as a man
and this is why I say it's very
important for us to understand the
person that we're speaking to and I'm
very glad that you clarified everything
that you mean not every man is like
Andrew Tate not every man is going to be
able to even
realistically demand for certain things
from a woman so the same way women need
to compromise if he comes to a man who
is going to cheat on her because he's a
top G in the same way men are going to
have to compromise and stop never
blabbing about purity
and you didn't get none of them I made
my point that was the whole point
I made my point
is that too many women they see regular
guys and they feel they're settling
you're not settling you're getting what
you deserve but you can't be asking
questions
but the difference is men know this like
most average men are the average men
wait wait wait the difference is average
men no they don't deserve a 10. they
know they don't deserve an eight they
know they don't even deserve a seven and
they still go messaging them on the
stores and all this dumb stuff that's
just ugly most men in history haven't
even reproduced and so it's like man no
but we the women are the ones that are
delusional's worth there's regular men
out there that will have you down can I
just say people are watching
standing that Tate is part of that one
percent of uh and they think that they
can demand the same thing
one second one second one second sorry
sorry I understand the point you're all
making but let's understand something
to the sexual Marketplace females have
always been and still to a degree are
The Gatekeepers it's men will you can
think about it in a very simplistic way
this is not the case but let's simplify
it for the sake of argument imagine men
will run around and [__] anything
and women are the ones who say yes or no
you are The Gatekeepers that have all
the power and this is what's actually
truly interesting about the sexual
Marketplace because whenever women go
there's not enough good men then why are
you [__] of course why would they be
good if you don't make them be good
you're a [__] losers
so women so you're talking about I'm
saying that you know the man a certain
level can't do certain things if you
were with Joe schmoe and he wasn't
treating you the way you believe Joe
Schmo should treat you then why you
wouldn't leave like do women women have
the gatekeeping so if you get Josh Moe
and he treats you like you're you're his
Queen trishi perfect good if you get a
[__] guy at the absolute upper
echelon's value and and you still don't
aren't happy with what he's giving you
then leave women are The Gatekeepers you
women actually have all of the Power
this is what's beautiful to about the
whole thing women are constantly
complaining you have all the power
you're the ones who get to choose do you
know who you should be mad at for all
this [__] I'll tell you you should be
mad at do you know who threw away all
the female power in the sexual
Marketplace promiscuous females because
now you got chicks who will bang anybody
without trying so why should a dude get
up and try now do you have any idea how
hard it is to actually be let me make
this clear do you have any idea how hard
it is to actually be no [__] a man
and I say this and women go oh yeah dude
as soon as most women encounter any kind
of problem the first thing you do is
turn to a man their man their dad the
mechanic the police a man if you
actually put a woman from a problem and
go no men they're like oh sh whoa [__]
it's a mental breakdown men day after
day especially if you're a high level
man let me make it something clear from
my life I'll talk from personal
experience I'm not just looking after me
I'm not just looking after my chick I'm
the guy and about 300 people's phone
books that they call when anything big
goes wrong you get arrested in Russia or
you need an extraction from Ukraine you
need a million dollars whatever it is
Kazakhstan abduction they call me I'm
the first phone call I'm fixing 400
different lives I'm a Problem Solver
chicks can't fix [__] any of this
[__] right this is how hard it is to be
a man and it's amazing amazing because
Society expects it of you but so do
women if you had a man be honest you had
a man and you went to your man and said
oh I've got this problem it's I can't
fix this it's broken the car Tire's
broken and he went I don't know
you would dry up like you'd be like well
[__] it with the [__] point are you
that's the truth you could see her and
go oh we'd call a mechanic no you
wouldn't you'd look at your man go what
do you mean you can't fix it
yeah and this is what she's saying about
your man will get up and go and you know
what's beautiful about masculinity a
bunch of times a man will go up and he
doesn't have a clue how to fix himself
but he'll go don't worry baby okay and
he'll stand up with no money and no clue
and he'll go out there and [__] try
and find a way because there's a man you
need to be useful it is so difficult to
be a man you have no idea the amount of
pressure that we're under from society
and from the women we even want to
associate with on a whole is difficult
just to keep all these things in mind
it's hard
you see what you just said about yeah
the top G that if that money could fly
planes and fly that
drop it down to if you were earning like
say 50 000 a year couldn't you be that
same person amongst your peers 100
that's what I'm trying to say 100 good
and also also you have to money doesn't
make you a top G no no money is an
amplifier so that's that's the first
thing about money money amplifies men
can make money money does not make men
if you're a dork and you get rich you're
a rich dork if you're a gene you get
rich you're a top G right so that's the
first thing about money and I agree with
you but traditionally and this is the
Baseline and once again when I say these
things I'm not looking to be attacked
from a misogynist I'm just commenting on
how I view the world and how I see
things traditionally a man primarily
gives his attention to a female to get
sex and she gives him sex back to get
the attention that's the swap right so
if I'm a dude and I want sex from a girl
I give her attention I talk to her I
hang out with her I spend time with her
eventually I get the sex that's how it
works but the higher value you are as a
man the more valuable your attention is
the more valuable your time is the less
you have to give it's like potency right
so I can give five minutes to a chick
and that's worth two weeks of some other
dude's time but that's the reality so
where you are on the scale is just
basically how much of your time you have
to give now you can still give all your
time to a woman treat her like a queen
be respected by your peers she can be
happy with you I'm not saying she will
be any in fact I'll argue she'll be
happier with that man than she'll be
with a [__] guy like me I'm not even
out here someone make chicks happy I'm
not even saying that I'm saying that
she'll get the amount of time that she's
gonna want from that man the amount of
attention is linked to his status but at
a true high level status of man it's two
DMS 10 seconds 10 seconds 10 seconds
this kind of leads into my next question
all right guys let's take second to hear
from our Channel sponsor Florida cops
are searching for two young women who
stole a 25 000 Rolex after a male
companion fell asleep during a late
night rendezvous at his condo according
to the Broward County Sheriff's Office
the man picked up the women from outside
a bar down the street and drove to his
place for cocktails though the man later
fell asleep his conniving companions
remained on high alert when the man woke
up the pair were missing along with his
Rolex watch and his credit card
situations like this are happening all
over the world and you have to be on
high alert to protect yourself one way
to protect yourself from identity theft
is with virtual Shield one it monitors
banking retirement and investment
investment institutions for potential
data breaches dark web scans social
security protection with 24 7 alerts and
can protect you and your family with up
to a one million dollar insurance policy
virtual Shield one also includes free
access to Virtual Shields industry
leading VPN with unlimited VPN access
and advanced VPN plus features to keep
your internet and cell phone browsing
activity Anonymous and private this
service also includes malware and ad
blocking with a 30-day free trial and 67
off this holiday season what do you have
to lose I use it myself and love how it
makes me feel safe by protecting my
identity and keeping my browsing history
Anonymous just click the link below or
simply visit virtualshield.com pearly
that's
www.virtualshield.com
pearly and protect your identity today
remember supporting my sponsor help
support the channel thank you guys again
do women prefer to be monogamous with a
low value man or share a high value man
well look at look at society and you
tell me ask me so so let's ask let's ask
the the Single Ladies what would you
prefer I would prefer someone who's
monogamous I left a situation where I
got the Bentley I had all that I had the
kids I had that that was great I want a
companion I want real love and to me
what monogamy means to me is someone
who's committed to themselves that's
like the answer is within you and to be
honest I feel like again like the sex
has been Lost in Translation and what it
means I don't care man or female it's
been lost as it's so sacred so for me I
have kind of taken those blinders off
where I'm like okay he has to be here
I'm okay with dating the trainer in
Austin Texas that's just where I'm at
like I don't need a certain thing
because I know what I'm wanting most
guys in that percentage are not going to
give me so I would rather have a
monogamous man than someone who can do
whatever
so you think the personal trainer is
going to be monogamous
they're like known for cheating no well
I mean I don't here's here's my thing
like I get it like I don't generalize
people because I'm one of the one of the
most misunderstood people online as well
and I feel like there's a lot more to me
and I don't like to just put everyone in
a box I'd like to get to know people so
no I'm not going to just say oh okay of
course he's gonna cheat on me like no
okay okay would you would you take a guy
that makes 35 000 a year and had a dad
Bob had a dad Bond I feel like for me I
would want someone who sorry go ahead
okay
um I pour into myself and I'm
accountable for my [__] I'm aware of
what I got going on I'm not gonna have a
a mom bod I'm in the gym I had a baby a
year and a half ago I'm in the gym four
to five times a week so I would want
someone who can match at least the the
work ethic now when it comes to money I
know for me I want to be able to I do
not want to rely on a man I have I have
literally done that before it didn't pan
out my favor okay because what happens
is you get the rug rip from under you
and then now you [__] get out [__]
give me the [__] keys it is it
isn't that so for me the lifestyle I
want I am responsible for so I don't
look for a man to make x amount of
dollars because anything that I want I'm
gonna get myself well because in my head
I feel like a guy is just as likely to
cheat if he's in the top 20 of like
looks
just as likely as okay you know what I'm
saying like it just doesn't let me let
me ask let me ask a quick question just
so I can clarify something because I
understand your points
you're saying you want a partner a life
partner are you sure and I'm not
accusing I'm genuinely asking are you
sure you're not confusing
the amount of time the man spends with
you with his monogamy because they're
different things because what happens a
lot of the time if a man's out here
chasing chicks he's barely home but
imagine you had a man who was home seven
nights a week he was always home I'm
talking about like an hour like during
his work lunch you don't even notice
then would you even give a [__] about
monogamy if you had all of his time
effectively would you really care I
still would care because I I feel like
that's still just an hour a day and
we're not it's not really quality time I
feel I really have been in so many
different situations again the trainer
in Austin to the NBA player baby daddy
like I I have seen all of that stuff and
it's just my personal experience and
perspective to where I want someone that
sees the value in the Grand Canyon and I
want somebody who I understand okay so
that's a good point and that's so just
ask the first question I'm gonna ask a
second okay
the realization you've come to is an
interesting one it is something that
happens especially to to females as they
mature don't you think it's strange or
why do you think that zero women on
earth choose those kind of men who they
perhaps have slightly lower status but
are are more likely to be uh loyal to
them and be monogamous Etc in the modern
world because like I said the world's
changed why do you think zero women
choose them when they're at the peak of
their choices so when a woman is 19 and
she can go anywhere she wants every man
wants her she's can go on any y'all in
Miami she can get flown out to Dubai
when she has all the choices in the
world why is she completely uninterested
in those kind of men and then when she
gets to a certain age of maturity and
all there's a whole new generation of
girls who have all the choices then they
sit there and go you know what I deserve
the monogamy and data and they all of a
sudden want to grow up and mature why
don't why does no woman decide that when
she actually is at her most valuable I I
feel like for like I said I don't like
to speak for all women I just speak for
myself but I know for me that I was
looking for a man for a lifestyle
something that I was not able to do
individually by myself so that's why
it's like well yeah I want to be able to
do this do that I want to go for the
football player that was just on GQ and
in reality now I realize well okay
there's a lot that comes with that I can
make my own money I don't necessarily
need that type of guy for the happiness
that I'm looking for again seeing
without you in the Grand Canyon is a lot
different than like okay here's money
for this here's allowance for that and
there's enough of my time asking why a
man that is 20 21 23 is not a top G like
a 30 40 year old woman your age actually
dictates your sort of maturity to a
large extent well I'm arguing the point
the point I'm trying to make is that
what I actually think happens especially
in the modern world because the modern
world's all [__] up and nothing's the
way it's supposed to be the traditional
life path of a female is she's 17 she's
18 she's 19 and her value is massively
inflated and I don't blame her of course
it's massively inflated imagine being 19
years old have achieved exactly [__]
zero in your life knowing nothing you
put makeup on and and sports stars
billionaires actors the most important
famous people on the planet the richest
man on the planet are begging for your
attention the ego you're going to
develop let's all be honest right the
ego you're going to development is gonna
be mon you [__] mental I'm special
I'm so gorgeous all this [__] right
and then what happens as they grow older
as new generations come along because
the truth is most women are are at their
Peak attraction let's say in their early
20s as they grow older what they what
women become is far more fearful of
competition this is why you'll see a
woman who's a bit older and go oh you
know I already want monogamy what she's
scared of is her dude getting a 21 year
old that's what she's [__] scared of
she may not know it she may not say it
but basically that's what the truth is
because she knows a 24 one year old is
gonna be more desirable higher status
more fertile that's what she's scared of
she's mad when you're 30. so no but I'm
not it's not about that I'm telling you
the the shift in the female mentality
because when a female is 20 she doesn't
give a [__] about any of this she
doesn't want to find the nice man now
she's trying to like you're saying
chasing a lifestyle chasing Mr
promiscuous chasing Mr famous doesn't
give a [__] until she starts getting
scared oh [__] oh my age begins with
three now and and then they change their
mentality changes it's a fear element
that's the reality and it's a biological
fear element I'll give you an example of
it you know what's amazing about humans
we are still very Primal if when when
men like these two and me when we walk
through the mall people just move it's
like you can sense when you can sense
when the big animals turn up right it's
something amazing about humans if you
have a very attractive 45 year old woman
she's gorgeous but a gorgeous 19 year
old walks in look at that 45 year old
woman's face she's Furious She [__]
hates her she just doesn't like her for
no reason because women understand on
unfortunes unfortunately but you're
innately your age is a massive indicator
in your value in an inverse weight to
men men are more valuable as we get
older every man every woman knows that
every woman will sit here and go yeah
well I know man who's older than me of
course but if I say the other around I'm
misogynistic it's just a reality of the
world so so then we have to go into the
other point the point is this when you
were at your Peak value you had zero
interest in monogamy but then you find a
man who's 35 at his Peak value he's
finally struggled and worked because
when he was 19 no girl spoke to him when
he was 23 he was broke when he was 24 he
had no life experience when he was 25 he
couldn't [__] when he was 20 whatever he
finally gets to the point where he's now
at his Peak value him at 35 is you when
you were 19. and then you're sitting
there saying to him no you should be
monogamous it's like well you [__]
weren't you did whatever you wanted in
your Peak now I'm finally got there and
I had to work for my [__] God gave you
God and L'Oreal gave you you I had to
[__] struggle I had to go through
hell to get on this yaw you go on the
yaw with an Instagram DM I had to buy it
and now you're telling me I need to
[__] settle down and behave and grow
up [__] yeah because [__] you're
assuming that the journey is a man that
starts with nothing to something because
there's a lot of men that's exactly the
Journey of every man on Earth we are
born without wow
so that's there's specificity in that
can I just because that's not how it
should be for everybody that's not how
it is for everybody and not for every
woman either is what may I just say and
that's Brittany something please
um you know like oh then you've learned
in the past and now you want to find
someone to settle down
with hindsight now would you reversed it
and like started young looking for
someone to settle down with looking for
those values that now you know I'm
talking about with hindsight okay well
I've I actually from 18 to 22 I was in a
relationship I've always actually been a
lover girl despite what I put out online
for you know yeah that's fine that's
even better
um I have always wanted one person and I
feel like I was so delusional in
thinking that oh I'm I'm like you said
like I have value I'm beautiful I'm this
I'm at my Peak like why wouldn't you
want to be with me so a lot going into
these relationships or just like P I'm
sorry just people my goal was always to
get commitment like I'm giving my time
I'm pouring into because I want
commitment and the reality is I'd never
had I never really understood my value
so I was going through guys giving up
sex doing this and it didn't make sense
so I believe in like I stay on
everything I do like I I don't I don't
do apology tours it is what it is and I
think that's where I feel like when it
when they talk about women being
delusional and all these other things it
is true because what you have to
understand is that there are
repercussions to your decisions which is
fine so then you're talking about okay
well I want this type of guy I want this
that and that you're talking about maybe
monogamy that's three to five percent of
animals are monogamous I think that's
what it is right so the your window is
really really small for what you're
looking for and even to go on to the
point where you said were you talking
about it's like a subconscious fear I
think it's like for me I feel like if it
was more of a fear I would have just
stayed in my situation like it wouldn't
have made sense like I mean that was my
first kid I thought I waited and did it
right I left because I believe it
there's something else on my heart when
it comes to love and I'm just gonna have
to trust that and if that means being
alone having a dog I have to take that
chance because the Bentley the ring the
house and still getting again deceived
right disrespected because deceit is
disrespect right so I just I cannot
settle for that I can't suck a dick and
shut up and that is where a lot of
people don't like my views and what I
represent because it is something new I
don't know how it's gonna [__] end I
don't know what's going to happen would
you tell your 17 if you had to like what
would you tell your 17 year old self
knowing what you know now looking back
in here to meet yourself at 17 what
would you tell your what would you tell
yourself like lock it down and wait for
the right man don't have sex what would
you tell your 17 year old self
um
that the answers aren't outside of you
because I feel like I'd always look for
men to answer all of my questions that
I've ever had I thought when I had a man
it would completely complete me and I
feel like too
um especially with like my dad not being
in my life you look for somebody to
guide me like so that's where for me I
put too much value in
someone else having the answers for me
so that's why I'm really big on
accountability so I I would just tell
myself like to be patient to take your
time because I was always quick oh let's
try to get in a relationship like we
weren't even compatible there's a lot of
just not compatible factors so I feel
like for me it would be to slow down and
to really get to know people instead of
just blindly banking on potential that
most likely will never be tapped into or
selling myself short because there's a
fear of well I don't know this could be
the best that I could get I might as
well just suck up shut up and suck it in
and that's what that's what I meant
about about women nowadays because
exactly what you'd be telling your 17
year old self is what happened back in
the day so when I'm repeating these
things I'm gonna oh you're old-fashioned
but it seems like women do what they
like and then they hit a certain age and
say oh well I've got to settle but it's
not settling you're just getting
whatever you can you know or whatever
you deserve you know what because if you
think back now you'd be telling people
now rather than say the auntie's
old-fashioned Auntie don't know what
she's talking about look what she'd be
telling her 17 year old so which ain't
nothing that I already said yeah because
let me finish let me finish because what
I've always said and you can check I'm
an older version of you
so where you've been I've already been a
comeback so that's why I asked you what
would you tell your 17 year old self
because me telling you is I'm telling my
30 year old self do you understand where
I'm coming from so it's not that I'm old
fashioned it's just that
women hit a certain age and then realize
oh my God it wasn't that old-fashioned
you know it works because it does but
there's no point in waiting until you're
a certain age to start thinking about it
you know even if you're like you hold
your own accountability so it's like if
you meet somebody and they were like 17
18 and you saw the match in a certain
way they asked you for advice you won't
say do as I do you say this one this
will happen to me and this is what I
thought and what I recommend you do is
blah blah blah around my own and I ask
you for your advice no I totally get
what you're saying like I totally agree
with that I I think that no matter what
you decide to do you have to accept
whatever repercussions come behind that
so any advice that I give to anybody is
do what you want but just know there are
repercussions good bad or indifferent
that are going to come behind it so I
mean and I think that's just where I'm
at I don't even think it's like an age
thing I think it's like in reality I
have I have a son and you really start
asking yourself questions and again I
hate that it took having a child to
really look into my life and call myself
out on my [__] but you got pregnant
earlier if you got pregnant at 18 19
would it I was always on birth control I
was on birth control for a decade I got
off birth control because the person I
was with when I have a baby so so um
again I thought I did it right clearly
not because I wasn't married but
um it still didn't work out because it
just wasn't my guy so that's where I
just think like even if I still would
have taken it slow there just for a lot
of people that just generally not my
person and that's okay
uh I was just speaking of speaking of
marriage um I wanted to know do you
think we're in a post-marriage society
because on one hand
um we hear that women should wait till
they're married to have sex but at the
same time we also hear from the men that
they don't want to get married anymore
so what do we do with that seems like
it's true because nowadays A lot of
people are looking at marriage as a
contract rather than a partnership
there's a huge difference between that
because with a contract there are so
many terms and many headaches and this
and I know it is a contract
yeah but that's because that is what it
is now because realistically the
traditional sense of marriage is not a
contract really in terms of the law once
the law is involved that's when
everything went it's up I think yeah so
the problem is is that there's zero
advantage to marriage in the western
world for a man there are zero
statistical Advantage if you use your
mind if you use your head instead of
your heart and you look at the
advantages of getting married there are
absolutely not really none because this
new idea of new age feminism just
basically destroys all men and the idea
in the event of her leaving
and and it's very common that women
leave right let's let's stop the a man
versus woman attack et cetera Etc life's
difficult for everybody we all have
different challenges different things to
go through but if a woman marries a man
and it goes wrong she has emotional
heartbreak fine but if a man marries a
woman and it goes wrong he has emotional
heartbreak plus everything he has ever
worked for is ripped out from underneath
him and he has to give that chick money
forever and some places you don't even
have to be married exactly that's why
the men don't want to live with the
women that's right so when you make
these rules and these laws right under
the guise of feminism and equality all
this garbage all you're doing is scaring
men away from commitment and then you
have to add in the other hidden element
and the other hidden element is what I
said earlier is whose fault a lot this
is is promiscuous women right so when
Society is broken down if women were
saying if all women got together and
said we'll only have sex after marriage
guess what men would do get married but
you don't right so now you're in Miami I
go Miami I can [__] anything in the club
I don't have to marry any of them if I
marry them I get wrecked so like let's
all use our Springs here what am I gonna
do well I'm gonna be like well no bounce
see uh no no so men have been scared
away from the idea of marriage and
that's a law that is the fault of this
new [__] law and this new feminism
and this new crap they don't give men
any tactical advantage and I'm talking
about small things a man's not even
allowed to be a man in his own house do
you know in England you will get accused
of emotional abuse I can marry a woman
not lay a hand on her I can just raise
my voice to her that's emotional abuse I
can raise my voice to her because she's
going out drinking with dudes she can go
out drinking six nights of night and
week with men and I can say what the
[__] are my wife sit down she can call
the cops call me emotionally abusive I
get arrested now now there's a court
case against me I have to go to court
and defend myself she'll divorce me take
my house I have to sell my car because
she's drinking vodka with [__] God
knows who but you notice that it's
Insanity what do you think of what do
you think of Child Support
and that's another interesting thing
because a lot of these arguments it's
it's it it goes beyond man and woman and
it goes into the the larger sphere as a
whole right because we talked earlier
about war and how a lot of men used to
die and that doesn't happen anymore so
what you used to have in societies and
I'm not saying I have all the answers
I'm just commenting right what you used
to have in societies is a bunch of men
would die at War because men have more
dangerous lives than women there'd be a
bunch more women than men the top G's
would impregnate a bunch of women and
the top G's could take care of the women
and not be etc etc that's now changed
right so the reason a lot of the reason
that monogamy is pushed is because it's
good for society and it is good for
society it's good for society as a whole
to have a man a woman a family they're
together the man provides for the woman
Etc the government doesn't want to pay
for all these kids if you don't have
child support he's paying for these kids
the government does it it breaks down
right so that's why child support is
enforced in many parts of the world in
certain other parts of the world child
support isn't enforced because they have
religious beliefs or genuine genuine
family beliefs that keep the families
together but in the Western World now
you need child support because you've
broken things down to the point where
men don't want to be married to chicks
chicks don't want to listen to the man
the man can't even be the man in his own
household he can't even feel respected
where he goes his woman gives her him no
status and and now he doesn't want to
[__] deal with her anymore so how do
you get that kid paid for well then tell
the man or you go to jail and you just
come along with a [__] long arm of
the law and you [__] him and so yeah
it's difficult it's hard to answer yeah
but it's hard to answer the true answer
to all of it is an idealistic answer I
don't like to think idealistically and
talk idealistically but it's the truth
the true answer to it is to instill in
the man a sense of Duty in which he
wants to take care of his woman
regardless because that's his child but
you will do that I'll tell you how you
do that you do that by inspiring out of
the man by being a very good woman so
I'll give you an example if I had a
child with a woman and she was always a
great woman to me she was never she
never cheated on me she was a good woman
to me and I was running around being
whatever and she's like look I just
can't put up with you anymore you're top
G you're going to do what you're gonna
do I'm gonna look after your kid I'm
gonna you can see him anytime you want I
care about you please
don't leave me in poverty I'd say cool
100 I'm like I'm not a [__] [__]
oh my God that's like a real man though
because I was in a situation just yeah
but I was just in a situation like that
to where it's like hearts don't break
even and that's the reality too it's
like if those morals and principles are
not instilled in a man none of that [__]
matters so obviously the child support
stuff obviously hits close home to me
because I'm already 50 000. it's just in
lawyer fees trying to get him to provide
yeah you know what I mean and it sucks
because it's like you play in the NBA
like why couldn't you why don't you want
to do more and it's just because again
of the relationship it's personal it's
not about ourselves that's right so it's
like yeah if you're not so I just I just
feel like it's like why do you get money
for making a poor choice well it wasn't
a poor choice because I'm not trying to
like disrespect you in any way it's just
like if you left and so it's yeah an eye
for it just right because we because we
made a commitment so we made it at the
end of the day we made a commit we have
a forever commitment [__] marriage we're
we are forever fan family so again as
someone who is literally going through
this if I made more money than him I
would be paying him child support and
that would be fair to me but this is
what's really interesting what's truly
interesting is if you go to other
countries and I'm talking about
civilized countries right if you go to
Poland or Czech Republic or whatever
these countries which are in many
metrics more civilized than the West
they're safer to live in they're cleaner
Etc there's no child support laws so if
you have a divorce the man just takes
care of the woman because that's his kid
and that's just what he's supposed to do
and that's just it so what you're saying
is he you're right about the man having
the morality instilled inside of them
and my point is that the reason a lot of
this doesn't exist the reason men don't
have morality installed in them is not
just about the individual case of the
man it's about society as a whole it's
about women as a whole men as a whole
the dating game as a whole the life he's
living as a whole and and it's and this
is the world we live in that's why I was
talking about how dangerous new think is
because now we have this new thing this
new world and we're living in this new
world and the truth is
as a man now your the game has changed
in the game of chess sometimes it's not
about winning it's about making sure you
don't lose if you cannot lose if you
could not blunder any pieces and protect
your king long enough you'll win the
game and there's a lot of men who are
now like okay how do I not lose well you
know what I become [__] ruthless
that's how I don't lose I get I get all
my sex because the women are promiscuous
I get laid as much as I want I don't let
anyone [__] tie me into anything dumb
any [__] wants to get fresh to me or
[__] talk to another dude I cut her
off financially but man you just forget
ruthless so you don't lose the game but
that's because the game's been rigged
against men so the harder you rig the
game against us the more ruthless we're
gonna have to be to compete and that's
it's unfortunate I'm not saying I have
the answers I'm just saying why men do
what they do Brittany I just think that
with regards to child support you've got
a kid you look after it and I do I don't
know
that's what I said no that's why I said
with regards to the child support that's
what I first said I think that you have
a kid that you should look after it I
don't agree that I don't agree with men
giving the women money but I think it's
disgusting that a man can have a child
and not support him so so why but this
is another thing so this is this is the
points we have to make right because we
don't have all the answers we have to
make the comments on it this goes into
the deeper point every time a court
rules in favor of a chick having a
hundred thousand dollars a month that
puts men off to a level like it's fine
if there was a baseline child support
thousand dollars a month two thousand
dollars a month that's if you have a kid
Baseline regardless of income if your
man wants to give you more he does if he
does whatever whatever when you come
along start saying this percent of a
man's income do you have an idea how
scary that is to a man who works for his
money he works for his money and you
know why it's scary it's not just
because he's giving his money away it's
because he knows he isn't giving money
to the kid yeah the kid you can raise a
kid on 500 bucks a month in most of the
world you want that kid in Gucci you and
Gucci you in a nice car going on dates
with another dude with my money you
could I'd rather burn the [__] house
down and give it to you
guys just for child support I just think
it incentivizes poor decisions like I
haven't gotten pregnant by someone but
like you someone but I'm saying but like
you're gonna you're gonna pay someone
who's done that like why did they get oh
no but I'm literally I'm literally
telling telling you that what if I made
more money than him I would have no
problem paying for my child and their
child child support laws vary in
different states so in North Carolina
for instance if you make over combined
over 300 000 a year then you are
considered Off the Grid so then you have
to prove this is how much my your rent
is any bill that my son occupies I get a
percent that I get a percentage of so on
the low end it would be 50 if there's a
big enough salary Gap it could be up to
97 in the court the judge gets to decide
what makes the most sense so if my
child's father makes 20 million dollars
a year from basketball he gets to decide
if six thousand dollars is a lot if
eight thousand or ten thousand whatever
but you have to prove that so it's not
like you just it's enough money for a
Chanel bag like these are a my son
watches Peppa Pig that's a part of
that's a cable bill you know what I mean
so it's it's a percentage of everything
so you're not like just living living it
up you're just living so you're able to
there's a roof over your son's head my
whole point is like it's all down to
choices and the man made a choice too
because I can't get pregnant unless he
nuts it I I understand that but I'm
and I didn't take a penny from him and
the government wanted me to but I
decided that now that he was better off
that my child I look after him myself
anything he wants to give his son if he
wanted to is extra but I worked hard and
I've done it all on my own because it
was this list because it's this headache
is this no it's not a lot of women that
went there though that you you have to
think that he's not going to be a man
and take care of his child don't you
think that's unfair on you not because
my children he's happy now I'm gonna
give him a child as well he made that
child
what are we talking about I'm saying
right now it's not fair because women
have abortion that's legal it's not
legal for them
they get no sand and the same thing with
birds I mean I could have done it could
have done but it wasn't worth my time
wanted the child though that's exactly
my thing
as an example my whole point my point I
think he should I think he should take
care of it I just don't agree with
having legal incentives for women to
leave that's my point he should give you
money for the kid if you have a kid you
should but I just don't agree with with
see but the thing is if men stood up and
became fathers to their children women
control we're in control of who we sleep
with so at the end
of you but you pick who you sleep with
so you pick a guy that's getting girls
pregnant but she doesn't know that he's
not gonna be there she doesn't know that
if she married him she'd be all right
she trusted this man to be your father
to a child and now she's left with a
child and No One's Gonna support her
don't you think that something should
have married him first I mean you can
get married
this is what solves problems
financial problems please don't cut me
off this is the problem yeah stop acting
like every woman that leaves a marriage
and gets divorces because she's this and
she's that there's a lot of women that
suffer they actually need the support
and the legal incentives so that they
know when they leave somebody can back
them up because they'll be on their own
stop acting like men are angels because
there's a lot of men that are dealing
with a lot of the traumas that they have
from a mass while being difficult the
same way that Andrew Tech explained a
man's world is highly competitive men
are out there suffering it is hard to be
a man and a lot of the time the person
takes the brunt of it is the woman so
yes she's well within her right to leave
take her child and be in a better place
and the government should step in to
make sure that that man that made her
make that decision steps in for that kid
wait the time that she takes to take
care of the child is the time that she
doesn't have to go to work so she's
already done on income and she's having
to be taking care of the child on her
own that don't make sense not every man
is a bloody Angel and not every woman is
the devil
right so now it's my time to talk talk
what I was saying to worries right is
that if she got married first
then should have been all right she'll
have to be fighting for the court so the
same law that you're saying would have
supported her and her child no that is
the difference between getting married
first and that's what I'm saying and
that's what when people were saying it
gives you more money
good decision yeah excuse me but I shut
up when you were talking no one
apologies
so what I was trying to say is that
there was an incentive when women get
married first and have children because
I'm not saying that I'm not saying that
you I'm just saying women in general if
a woman gets married first before she
has a child and then it leaves then it's
totally different like he said before
she set up for life and she leaves she's
out for life so if somebody else without
marriage though that's the point
you want to hear no and as a person
again let's ask somebody who's actually
going through because none of you
[__] know what the [__] you're
talking about when it comes to child
support lawyers none of that [__] none
of you [__] know okay so you don't
the reality is if I would have gotten
married and did everything right and did
everything the moral way right guess
what all I would have a dish on top of
what I'm going through with child
support is alimony so I'm still in the
courts fighting whether I'm married or
whether I'm not so that I get what
you're saying because you at least get
the commitment to you know maybe back up
that he's gonna be there but it doesn't
ensure anything everybody wants a
[__] guaranteed thing there's no
guaranteed in life we're talking
different places when you're in America
and you're married and you divorce
you've still gotta fight for your money
not in England in England you get a
lawyer and it's sorted that's the
difference you're gonna have to be going
there saying oh I need this for my child
and I need this you get once you get
divorced and you go to court it's that
much I'm saying she just spent 50 000
pounds she's still fighting you have to
pay that here you would not have to pay
that yeah
you would not have to pay the hair do
your research you would not have to pay
that here well you get divorced she
wouldn't be going for all the battle
that she's going it'd be simpler in
England to get divorced than in America
in England take your money don't get
married you have a parental partnership
I just want to make a point you know
what you were saying get married even
Tate said himself men don't want to get
married anymore he's saying why are you
not twisting what you're saying he's not
even listening to what he's saying
anymore
and you're twisting it to suit yourself
take didn't you say that men are scared
of getting married now what yeah okay
but why because like you said with child
support they feel like there's no
Advantage
it's not that simple because men don't
want to marry you oh okay so let's let's
analyze that point and first and first
thing back to the child support thing
what's actually interesting to talk
about is there's a lot of countries in
the world where there is no child
support system and it functions right so
you have to if you want to pay attention
to actually you know learn about society
as a whole it's very interesting to
study all the different societies and
economies in which there is no child
support and and children don't die I
mean people get divorced and they still
find a way to function and it's
interesting and it's a very long
conversation because it extrapolates
about how the whole society works as a
whole that's the first point second
thing I'll actually sit here and argue
the point that I don't think any man
really ever wants to get married I think
that women convince them to get married
and I think that any woman who is
genuinely serious about convincing her
man to get married could do it I don't
think in the modern world at least men
wake up and go can't wait to get married
but what they do is they get a chick
who's so good and ticks so many boxes
and makes them so happy and she'll sit
there and say you know what it would
mean the world to me
please and he'll go off for [__] sake
all right then and that's what happens
so I still think you can convince 99.9
of men to marry you the point I was
making is the society Society isn't
convincing the man to marry you it's not
like it used to be where the man
believed he had to be married Society
has done the opposite so it's your job
as a woman to make it clear to him that
it is worthwhile once again how would
you convince a man it's worthwhile for
him to say that's my wife
status that's how you do it this is the
under a misunderstood hack to to men as
a whole is status if you can say if you
can convince that man by marrying you
his status will increase amongst his
peers he's going to do it and for anyone
out here who disagrees with me the
things men do for status let's actually
analyze how Baseline men are what is
stata status is respect right men kill
over respect men gangs kill each other
over respect a man will smash another
man's face in for insulting him we will
die for respect and stay is you tell me
we won't get married we'll die for her
we'll go to the front line of a war and
the only reason we don't walk away and
abandon our post as artillery shells let
rain is because we're afraid of being
mocked for being a coward we'll die for
status so status is what it's all about
it's what it's always been about if you
want a man to marry you status and it's
the same thing with nearly anything you
want to do with a man I don't know
anything about your personal life I'll
be honest I don't know right but I'll
tell you this now if this dude semba
player believed that he would be higher
respected amongst his peers and among
Society for taking care of you properly
that's what he'd [__] do he doesn't
feel that because either he's rolling
with the wrong people or you've pissed
him off in a way or something Publix
happened I don't have a clue but
something's happened where he feels like
if I take care of her I'll look like a
[__] that's what he's scared of if it
was inversed he had no problem giving
you money because that's how men
function I'm telling you right now as a
man I'm telling you what I would do if I
had a chick with a woman right and she
went on the news Talk Jesus and [__]
and this like I said I have no idea what
you've done but I was given my personal
made-up scenario shoot it on the news
Talk Jesus and he [__] lied to me
he's a piece of [__] and then I bought
her a Bentley Williams I'm like well
look she insults she insults him and
he's [__] he's a sin but if she was
like you know what he he's misunderstood
he's a good guy it just didn't work out
but she'd be in a mansion right and
would that be me being a nice guy caring
about her or let's be honest would it be
me being a selfish piece of [__] dude
and saying what makes me look better man
are all about status is how we function
it's how we function as a whole so
Society this is where it extrapolates it
gets interesting when Society with this
new thing has destroyed all of the
Baseline Humanities and Baseline
understandings of how men interact with
women and now all the things we
previously understood about what made a
good man what made a good woman and how
we should act together and how we should
interact has been erased of course men
are acting like [__] and of course
women are doing wrong things nothing
makes sense anymore you've taken the
chess board and moved all the [__]
pieces around nobody gets it it should
be very simple I'm a man I work hard I
take care of my woman I'm the man of the
house she treats me with respect she
would never insult me or raise her voice
to me in front of other people she's a
problem she brings it to me in private
we act as a team we work together if we
break up she was a good woman to me she
fulfilled her roles the best she
possibly could I'm still a man I'm gonna
take care of her but all of that is gone
all of it's gone all of it and it's gone
because of all the ideas we were
discussing earlier the feminism the new
age [__] [__] dudes left and
right and Center that all these things
all these Baseline things have eroded
Society to the point where now you have
men ignoring their paternal Instinct you
have men who will sit there and go
that's my child but [__] her
that that is that that's actually a
massive observation to make about how
[__] up Society is and it's all and it
shouldn't be that way because men in a
lot of the world are not like that
because so you have to look at all these
small things the small things we talk
about it's no big deal she goes on boats
in Miami it's no big deal it is a big
deal because now that dude ain't gonna
want to [__] pay child support
because you were on those [__] boats
with this [__] the other team
do you think do you think that men not
as well say Sagittarius thank you very
much do you think that men marry for
like high status families like I'm
thinking of like Ivanka Trump like would
someone marry a girl for like status in
that way well that is one of the most I
mean if you look at arranged marriages
his office status right that's an
example but men men primarily married
for I I'd argue that men and I say this
about men but women do the same thing
right women love the idea of getting
stays from a man women love the idea and
this is where it actually gets a bit
messy the waters get muddy because women
love the idea of bragging about the man
they're with but they can only brag
about the man that are with if other
women want that man so you're saying you
love women who get cheated women love
getting cheated on that's not true but
women do not like men that other women
don't want if you were to say look I got
my man he's perfect he's rich and every
girl in the room would go I would never
touch him she was like oh [__] well I
don't want him either then what the [__]
you know I don't talk about that so but
but it's true right women women want men
that that all the women want do you know
what's the best man that woman wants is
the one that every girl wants paid
doesn't want them a selective man I'm
sure that's more valuable than the
topics
and women should accept that that's the
problem men are continuously
disrespecting their woman like yeah you
know what you want you can't be with one
woman now you want to keep cheating with
all these days that's not what he said
he's saying if you're gonna go if you're
gonna go for a high status guy if you're
gonna go for the top five percent of
guys that's what comes with it and if
you're not then go for the average guy
can I just say that before is it okay
for average guys to stick with one woman
then it's not about okay okay it's okay
for anyone to do whatever they want I'm
not sitting here saying what's okay and
what isn't okay what I'm talking about
is observations about the Baseline
realities of how humans function what
I'm telling is if you give a man
unlimited options like the men at the
top of society have on a long enough
time scale he will explore set options
that is a fact like I said earlier you
can walk into a car garage and buy a
Nissan and that's reliable and I'll
never let you down or you can buy a
McLaren you cannot sit like women do and
go I want the McLaren that's reliable
electing this sand well guess [__]
why that's not real so you have to
choose
something years ago right do you do you
think it makes a difference because
years ago if you want to meet a man you
go out there you actually talk but now
you meet a guy you can go and check out
your ID and see what you're all about
can't don't you think that by them being
able to look and see what you're all
about that makes a difference that they
perceive you 100 I think Society is
fundamentally and utterly broken I think
the way that men and women interact is
broken I think that men are broken I
think that women are broken I think
everything is completely [__]
genuinely and and this is where we go
into the small things we're talking
about status you're right about IG if I
go on a date with a girl and I look at
her Instagram page I'm sitting there
thinking does this make me look good or
bad yes I want her to be hot yes I want
her to have followers yes I want
everyone chasing her but what's that
caption about about [__] City Life
what's this about what's that that's not
that's not nah that puts me off right so
it's interesting what's also interesting
is the majority of women don't have a
clue in the modern world what men find
attractive so we said earlier in the
very beginning of this podcast about men
who want their dick sucked most [__]
men don't that's not attractive to men
we don't want any of that most women if
you were to say how do you attract a man
they wouldn't have a Scooby-Doo they
wouldn't have an idea I know they want a
submissive woman hello
give him some massage
[Music]
it's not just it's not just about that
the the one of the one of the important
things for being a man especially in a
relationship is we want to be our woman
if I have a woman and I love her I want
to be her portal to the world I want her
to experience things through me and see
things through me so for that I need a
degree of Innocence impurity for her I
want to be the first person to put her
on a private jet I want to get on the
Jet and go wow oh you took me it's like
giving you wouldn't want to give someone
a Christmas present if they'd had 10
presents better than you beforehand yeah
it's like well so as a man so as a woman
what makes you attractive to a man to a
degree is your innocence and your Purity
this is very important and it can go
down to very basic simple things I'll
tell you if I walk in a club do you know
who the hottest girl in the club it's
the girl who isn't dancing isn't
twerking on a [__] dead stage not
surrounded by dude girls when girls want
male attention in a club they start
drinking twerking that is the most
revolting Haram [__] I may want to
[__] you but I don't want to be with you
if you show me a girl sitting in the
corner shy I'm like good she hasn't
experienced too much life I can show her
thing and also not just show her things
this is a very important point that I
get attacked by The Matrix Forks they
completely misunderstand me on purpose
as a man if I'm out here struggling and
leading and trying to leave my household
I also want a woman who shares my values
I want to a degree to educate my woman
and show her things and for her to agree
with me like you said earlier looking
for a male role model you want to be a
role model to your woman if she's too
experienced with life it's difficult to
be a role model if she's sitting there
shy and quiet you can come along and say
no you know what don't take the [__]
vaccine listen to me and you can be a
role model for her you can't do that for
a woman who knows too [__] much knows
too many dudes been too many places so
it's this degree of Purity that we're
looking for that's super important
I'm curious if you said if she's like
done too many things that's like bad
right that's correct so not I'm not even
talking sexually like that on a private
jet I'm curious because I lived so how
do you get on a private jet without
sucking dick oh I was just curious
because my my dad's part of like he's
top like one percent in terms of like
income and I was just curious is it
different if you did stuff with your dad
well no that's fine
yeah but no but my point is that we're
looking for a true degree of Innocence
inside of females and it's that
innocence that's going to make us feel
protective over them and that the
protectiveness is going to make us be
good men so so when we're looking at
society as a whole and how broken it is
I understand that men have a massive
role to play women of a massive role to
play but a lot of the paternal instincts
and instinctual behaviors of men because
the instinctual behavior of man is to
die for his woman like someone comes to
try and take her pull a sword die to
defend her right if you're if you're
going through life and you find that men
don't really feel about you that way
that's because a lot of their instinct
is being eroded by the fact that you
like you said they look through your IG
or they look through your life and
you've lived so much life and they just
feel like there's nothing new I can
bring to this girl's reality I don't
feel like that's true though because
like I think it's like I get what you're
saying to a degree right but it's like
you could be on a private jet 10 times
but it's going to be special because
it's with you not for him it isn't not
for him for him it's special because
it's your first time because men and
maybe it's a biological predisposition
maybe it's just the way we're designed
but let's let's tie it back to sex
virginity first time it's not that
you've done it so you've done it with
the first time with me that's what is
important it's experience as a whole
that men find it's just the truth call
me misogynistic cancel me whatever I'm
telling the truth I always have done
it's experience of Life as a whole that
men to a degree find off-putting we
don't want a woman who's had a bunch of
trauma had a bunch of experiences done a
bunch of [__] knows a bunch of people
been a bunch of places that's the
absolute opposite of what we want we
want the complete polar opposite of that
and what's funny is women want men who
have who have done those things I'll
tell you right now go out there and find
a virgin woman and say do you want to
have your first boyfriend do you want to
lose your virginity to a virgin man or a
man or a man who who's had a couple
girls she'll choose a dude with
experience as a virgin herself
experiences is always commented and
respected in men it's the opposite in
women so it's true so we have to look at
how [__] up the world is women
especially in their between their 18 and
28 or 18 and 25 let's say are living
these crazy Lifestyles these crazy lives
with the most important people richest
people on the planet doing everything
that can be experienced Under the Sun
and then at 29 30 some dudes expected to
come along know he's second place to XYZ
and be happy with that and and and and
and and not not allow it to hurt his ego
and and sit there and pick it up and put
a [__] Brave face on it kills him
every day inside that's the reality he's
in love with you and you've been [__]
where with [__] who I got afford a
jet I'm Joe schmoe that [__] breaks
their hearts do you do you think that
hoes can never be turned into Housewives
okay I'll answer that question and the
answer is actually truthfully yes
which I know a lot of people are
confused to buy they can if you're a
good enough high enough level man you
absolutely can turn a hoe into a
housewife but why the [__] would you
because you don't have to a man like me
I could but I don't I don't have I'm not
low odd option so I would never decide
to do that if you're a billionaire could
you you know you can find an old rusty
car and rebuild it or you can just buy a
new one right so it's not that it's not
about what could be done it's about what
will be done so once women here certain
state is a man I don't think women are
stupid and I actually argue the fact
that women have a beautiful intuition I
think that women to a degree their
intuition is truly almost psychic the
number of girls number of times I've
come home and she's like you're cheating
and I was like how the [__] [__]
chick you have intuition and it's real
you guys are you guys are smart right
and if they get to a certain Echelon of
man they're not going to go anywhere
because there's nowhere else to go
they're gonna get to a guy eventually
they're gonna stop at the buck and go
you know what
where am I going to surpass this
specimen so I'm just going to behave for
him so you could turn a hoe into a
housewife that way but why would a man
at that level want to do why why do some
um guys at certain and this is obviously
a celebrity example but I'm sure we can
all think of examples in like day-to-day
life where a guy with a lot of options
does pick a hoe and like wife her like
for example Kim and Kanye
because it kind of clearly has options
she did not want to be a housewife no
she was a project okay I understand I'm
just asking because some guys do pick
yeah they do and it's a really good
point and I have nothing bad to say
about Kanye in fact I think a lot of the
work he's doing now in terms of
attacking the Matrix is is important but
I can give you a generalized answer but
it's a man who is not true to his
masculine imperative which is going to
fall for the propaganda machine which is
being purported upon him who's going to
believe that all the crap that is being
told by Society like a female's past
doesn't matter and all this [__] doesn't
matter this is what's interesting in the
fight against the Matrix because people
always say to me Andrew why do you come
here and say all these things they're
literally trying to destroy your life
for what you say and the truth is as a
man you have two choices you either
fight against the programming in the
brainwashing they're trying to put
inside of all of our minds or you end up
fighting against yourself if you're a
man and you sit down and you believe the
garbage that Society is telling you
about the how Society functions between
men and women you're going to end up
getting [__] wrecked like these dudes
do they sit there and go just because
she's [__] everyone doesn't mean
she'll do it again just because and they
sit there are dummies and they get
[__] wrecked right you have to sit
there as a man and go no I don't give a
[__] what Society is telling me I
understand something Baseline about
Humanity right and that's why they make
these poor choices and a lot of men do
make these poor choices but it's only in
the west it's only in the west where
this propaganda machine exists you will
not find a Russian billionaire doing
this dumb [__] you will not find a
Chinese billionaire doing this dumb [__]
you do not go to Saudi and find a shake
doing this dumb [__] none of it you only
find it in the west do you do you think
the values of the West are spreading
what what values
sorry
I met him I mean like the ideas of the
West like I've heard I've just gotten
like I get messages from people like
from all over and like in places like
India I've heard feminism is spreading
there like I've heard that do you not
find that to be true
so firstly the West has no value the
only thing the West seems to defend
fervently is LGBT I'm not saying
anything bad about it I'm not I'm just
saying it's the only thing that they'll
stand up and fight for I don't know why
it's weird like they don't care about
anything else they don't care about
children going without child support
they don't care about people dying in
Wars they don't care about our old our
parents being in parent and homes they
don't care about crime they don't care
about don't be able to pay their energy
bills they don't care about nothing but
they give a [__] some for some reason
about this one thing and they'll [__]
throw the flag all around the world
surrounded around six that's that's all
they care about it's [__] strange so
that's the first thing about the values
of the West second thing the harder
society and the harder the life is as a
whole the longer it's going to take for
feminism to spread feminism only exists
in a vacuum of an easy life if you're
living in a society like India where
life is hard feminism disappears because
the harder life is the closer people
naturally revert to their gender roles
if you've got a bunch of 10 men 10 women
stranded them on a desert island and
they had to survive very quickly the men
would do men's [__] and the women would
do women [__] there'd be very little
talk about feminism and equality and all
this [__] would [__] vanish when [__]
hits the fan right so in countries where
life is harder feminism can't take hold
because feminism can only exist in a
vacuum of a very privileged life I'm
sure there's some kid in India who
didn't get laid off some chick and he's
complaining she's a feminist there's a
bunch of dumb [__] right but but
I think the world is going to get a lot
harder I think the world is cyclical I
think it's been easy for a while I think
hard times are coming and when hard
times come people are going to naturally
revert to what gives them the highest
chance of survival which is gender roles
right I have the best chance of survival
being a man and a woman has the best
chance of survival being my woman that's
how she's going to function do you think
women typically are happier
um as Housewives rather than a career
well depends on the career no it depends
on the man the answer is absolutely not
really yes because giving life is the
most beautiful thing a female can do
that's what you've evolved to do that's
the thing that men cannot do I think
that women who focus on having children
and do their best to be good mothers in
the end are the happiest females on the
planet being a mother and being a
housewife is kind of different though
okay no but it's it's essentially the
same thing if you're a housewife long
enough I'm going to assume you're gonna
end up having children and I think that
the sooner a woman has children the
better if she can find a good man and
have a child that's a fantastic thing I
think it's a beautiful thing and I don't
see the point in a woman slaving away
for a corporation that doesn't care
about her as opposed to slaving away for
her own flesh and blood I think that's a
complete waste of a life I think if men
are already doing that why would you
want to go along and do that because the
story is not just living away for a
corporation a career can involve a
million different things well that's
exactly what a career is it's slaving
away for a corporation that doesn't care
about you and I understand you have to
pay the bills and I understand you don't
want to be completely sufficient you
want to be self-sufficient you want to
be dependent on a man I understand all
that but an idealistic scenario in the
vacuum of ideology if you could sit and
have and be a woman and focus on having
children or focus on doing a job I think
on a long enough time scale you're gonna
be much happier with your progeny as
opposed to working a job can I ask you a
question because I feel like we talk a
lot about hoes we talk about a lot of
the extreme there's a lot of great
matter in the middle sure where a lot of
women kind of get lost for example
I think that one of the issues sometimes
that I hear a lot about and I personally
may say I feel it sometimes is that when
you're also a quite educated woman
intellectual intelligent whatever smart
a lot of the time naturally you speak in
a way that stands out from other people
right and I find that a lot of the time
that kind of intimidates some of the
mandem where they start thinking this
girl is a bit too much now it is not my
fault I'm smart it's not my fault I can
put one and one together very nicely
very quickly
give me a minute
this woman laughs like I don't speak for
language I don't got three degrees what
is she trying to say you're not smart
it's okay I think so I do four reasons
so please sir can you help me out I'm
trying to find the husband the kind of
Beast that can handle a woman like me
well well this well this is another
point right and and I'm only answering
generally right because this is the
first time I've met all of you ladies
you've all been very polite to me you've
all been very nice I'm just talking
generally
and I'm going to answer it based on your
last sentence your last sentence was
handle a woman like me let's let's look
at the average man's life like I just
discussed earlier how difficult it is
how competitive he has to be and how
many problems he has to fix do you think
he wants to handle any woman okay so
dude like the idea of any degree of
problem
it's the straw that breaks the camel's
back like the the point of the point of
having a woman as a man for me at least
is for her to be my peace and quiet I
have my life is stress you see me I'm
rolling around with [__] security
teams and I got problems and they're
after me and I I when I come home to my
chick the last thing I want to do is
have to handle anything I want to just
sit the [__] down and her make me happy
she used to be my positive energy she
used to be my sunshine in the rainstorm
okay so you're talking about I can
handle you I don't know I can't answer
the question exactly but if you're
sitting there constantly arguing over
small points or correcting him or that
he's probably thinking this is a battle
I don't have the energy to for another
fight okay so now let me add extra
context what I mean as well so obviously
submission is something that people talk
about a lot for me I'm a logical person
I believe and I submit with logic I
don't submit by default because there's
a level of respect that I believe I need
to have yes to be able to submit
obviously you know that I go around and
I disrespect old men and everything but
I find that my level of
thought process a lot of the times
it makes a heart note so I don't I know
what you're trying to say yeah I think
you no but you need to find a man you
truly respect to submit to him and I
completely respect that and that's the
same with that's the same with 99 of
women like you you're never going to
submit to a man you don't respect and
and respect is ultimately important
because you're not going to sleep with a
man you don't respect you're not gonna
be attracted to a man you don't respect
respect is the bottom line of it and the
man has a job to do he has a duty to do
to be worthy of respect but this all
goes back into a very interesting point
some of the points I've kind of
mentioned earlier if I was a woman if I
was a chick the chance of me ending up
in a relationship with a man I don't
respect is zero percent I don't
understand how you girls end up well I
do understand how you girls end up here
you end up here because of feminism
promise QE promises that running around
taking dick is fine dumb [__] stupid
decisions I'm independent so it doesn't
matter he's a dummy bunch of garbage
when you should be waking up going you
know what I'm going to be extremely
selective and I'm going to take my time
and be very very smart because you're
the gatekeeper by the time you're in a
relationship with somebody you should
have immense respect for that man
absolute immense respect you shouldn't
be able to get there any other way the
only reason you've got there is because
you've been tricked by society and lied
to and told a bunch of [__] [__]
so yeah so you're talking about
submission and respect yeah it'll come
when you meet the right man naturally
and this is another point I make because
I have a lot of men message me I trust
guys please understand the most Googled
man on the planet I have the hundred
thousand emails a day thank people and I
get dudes email me how do I get my woman
to submit and I don't reply to I can't
reply to all the emails but I if I ever
read them I'm like bro you're a [__]
dork why would she reply to you why
would she submit to you you're a [__]
nerd that's the truth I'm not out here
saying submit to all men men are the
boss I'm saying listen there's Natural
Balance in the universe when you meet a
g I've never had a truck I've never had
trouble with a woman obeying me she just
wants to it's natural for our Dynamic if
she didn't want to obey me we wouldn't
even get to the point of a relationship
if she didn't feel like she wanted to
listen to me we would have never got to
where we want to get it just doesn't
work that [__] only happens when the
females [__] giving up sex too easy
and the dude's just picking up easy
[__] and they end up in some [__]
relationship they don't even like each
other that's dumb [__] that's dumb [__]
right but I don't have any of these
problems in my life and if you're a dude
at home and you're watching this and you
go I want my woman to submit and she
doesn't guess what she doesn't respect
you and guess whose fault that is a lot
of the time your fault that is your
fault as a man
it is yes no no it is yes no no that's
all you guys need to damn here tell him
I'm not blaming men and women because
everyone has a problem but but then
there's also men who are worthy of
respect to women refuse to respect
because of society
there's two sides to it right but a lot
of it is if you're a capable enough man
and you're brilliant enough then the
female has no choice but it's very
interesting this goes back into a point
I made earlier about how important it is
for us men to find women who we don't
believe have had a lot of life
experience and look like they are
because I got attacked I'm gonna make
this point right now I got attacked when
the Matrix attacked me and [__] lied
about me they said that men are
interested in women who are younger
because they're more programmable and
that they're trying to make out that I'm
making out that men are out here trying
to get women and [__] do bad things
to them no what I'm saying is if you
find a woman who's younger and do less
things less trauma less relationships
less headache she's lived less life your
ideals if you ask any woman who loves
her man what's your favorite song his
favorite song who do you vote for who he
votes for what's your favorite car his
car that's not what happens when a woman
loves a man and that makes the man feel
good right if she's been through too
much [__] then that's a lot harder to
pull off so that that that that that
link is very important for men and women
but um so yeah the Matrix attacked me
with that but it's very very interesting
you have to understand all these small
subdynamics and why things are happening
and why the world is the way it is and
the Baseline of it is is that
everything's [__] men aren't acting
like men and women are acting like women
and it's all messed up oh yeah so what
about like your own autonomy and like
just like you can your favorite card is
your favorite car my favorite car is my
favorite card like why does it have to
okay I guess that's where I'm going to
use yeah why does it have to be like
that yeah and that's a good point right
I understand that completely but I'll
give you an example I'll talk from
personal experience because it makes it
easy for me I have a bunch of cars I
love cars I have 32 cars my favorite
car's X I pick up a chick this is my uh
what's your favorite car this one I like
that one I'm like all right cool
whatever no big deal but
agreeableness is ultra attractive it
depends what the woman wants to do right
if I was a woman and let's say let's say
I'm let's say I'm 22 years old and I
meet a billionaire and it's my goal to
marry this man and I go to his house and
I say wow you have so many cards what's
your favorite car this one really I
thought that one too it looks so good
why that one because this is this oh
really okay I'll try and remember that
that's how you get the dude right you
don't get the dude by going well that
one is a better color you're a [__]
dude it's it's it may be small things it
may be tiny things but men are Ultra
interested in things like agreeableness
so Ultra interested in the idea of a
woman absorbing Our World Views we're
Ultra interested we are that's what
we're looking at away from the woman
wait what if you say she doesn't like
the car no no no why should she agree
why do you want to be with someone
can I say oh this is
quite nice you know actually now that
I'm looking at it it's quite good but I
like this one but I like that one as
well
men don't want a girl that's nagging on
them for the smallest things it's like
why are you giving a guy ahead
it's not lagging though he's saying he's
saying oh what color do you like why
does she have to say his car right she
likes a difference
I'm talking about I am talking about how
as a female to be as attractive as
possible to men now I'm not saying you
can't get a man if you say another car
I'm saying how do you be as ATT
attractive as possible because that's
about it because you also don't
understand how men think it's different
if you come to my house and choose to
like another one of my cars but what if
I only have one car and now you say well
no I pick up my BMW oh yeah it's nice I
prefer Mercedes you know what man thinks
the second you say that who picked you
up in a Merc that's the first thing that
goes to his [__] mind who how do you
know about Mercedes what if you can buy
your own Mercedes that's not what
crosses the man's mind I'm telling you
how men think but then that's why
I'm really happy for you I'm really
happy for your car but the average woman
I'm saying what person but the whole
point is that what percent of women even
earn that much it's not a high
percentage so when a guy hears them wait
wait wait when a guy hears that you've
been in this car and that car in that
car his automatic assumption is that
you're an average girl in that
foolishness and that and that you've
been with a bunch of guys to get to that
point I I've had a lot of experiences
because of my dad because my dad's very
successful but I've been in situations
where I've said like oh I did this I did
this I did this and they think it's with
a guy but it's with my dad because most
guys assume that you were an average
person
meaning
how can get a balance of probabilities
if I if I meet an average guy I assume
he makes average money I I think it's
just amazing
wait it's based on a balance of
probabilities and as you say something
but it's all about making a man feel
like he everybody says oh he's a top G
but it's like if your man put up a light
fitting
and you're standing watching a part of
the light fitting are you doing Alva
you're they're watching a man put a
light fitting what would you say while
he's putting it up and how would you
react I'd be like you're probably doing
it wrong but I'll let you finish
all right then but hang in a minute and
how would you act if your man was born
thank you baby okay well I'll be like
see the thing is no just answer the
question just answer the question what
would you say after your mum was putting
up the light fitting I'm just asking
questions
thanks for putting up the like button I
appreciate you my man put up a light for
me and I was like wow he got it all out
it was all in boxes he got his toolbox
he was up there in the ladder whatever
you want me to hand you I was like oh my
God you're stripping Myers oh my God
then he said I'll turn when it finished
I was like it works that's what he's
talking about I agree that is what he's
talking about when he's talking about
the car he's not saying you can get your
own car he's saying make the man feel
like he's doing something make him feel
appreciated like act like a child
you know and that's what he's saying
he's not saying that oh yeah you don't
like that car it's like my man got a car
he's like oh my God it's got to hit your
seats
I
think I I like to make my money I when
my mom dresses up I'm like girl you look
so fine like I like to make my mom feel
good but he has to do that to me as well
listen right he has to offer me that
song to Mr Tate right say about anime
but for instance there's an artist that
I like my man likes it too
covert had just sort of like finished I
got two free tickets to go to the to go
my man said to me you're not going what
would you do
I'm going what would you do
why why am I not going it doesn't matter
he said to you because that's just
illogical submission
no but the whole the whole point is you
pick someone that you respect enough to
trust his judgment even when you
disagree I want to I want to fight I
don't agree with it
just because you're in a relationship
wait wait wait we need one at a time why
would you think it's something stupid or
whatever you trust a man enough to be
with him you trust the man enough to
sleep with him so why won't you trusted
opinion why does he have to give the
everyone say to my man like if I say to
my man don't do this the first thing is
you're thinking not she's telling what
to do there must be a reason behind it
why she's telling me not to do because
she trusts me I did not go I had two
free tickets I did not go I'll tell you
what wait wait wait Auntie you asked me
a question I'll tell you why because the
same way a man wants that sort of
validation a woman wants Assurance I
don't want to just blindly do everything
all the time especially sometimes
thinking okay okay so let's talk that's
what submission is
made a really important point because
this the point she's making is twofold
and it's extremely important because a
lot of women talk about being submissive
but they're submissive when it suits
them that's not submission so she wanted
to go to the concert he said no she
trusts him as a man she didn't go
absolute respect for that that's exactly
what my woman would have done exactly
the same thing women go I'm submissive
you're submissive when he's buying you
[__] in bed and you're submissive but
the second he says something you don't
like you instantly turn off the
submission run your [__] mouth that's
all submissive that's manipulation
that's [__] so that's the first
thing the second thing is responsibility
in Authority are linked
and if as a man if I'm going to be
responsible for a woman I need a degree
of authority over her this is the
reality of it if I'm going to be
responsible for paying your bills and
responsible for your personal safety and
responsible for your personal
development responsible for fixing the
life fitting and responsible for
everything that I'm supposed to do as a
man I need a degree of authority to
sometimes come along and say XYZ and be
obeyed if I'm going to have a ship if
you have a ship the reason the captain
has to go down with the ship is because
he is responsible for everything that
happens on that ship and because of that
he has Authority if he yells at the
Shipmates and they all ignore him then
he can't be considered responsible for
the problems on the ship which means he
doesn't have to die with it if you want
a man invested in a relationship he
needs to be responsible for you but he
needs authority over you and you know
what the smartest thing you do as a
woman is sit and go you know what go
into this concert is two hours but this
is gonna piss him off and it'll be a
splinter in his mind for years this is
really worth it now I'm not saying let
some man abuse you let some man treat a
[__] but if you have a good man who's
good to you 99 of the time and he comes
along and he really cares about
something you should give him that Grace
and give him that you know what he's the
man he said it boom done because if
something happened to you at that
concert
if your bag was snatched if you got
[__] robbed if someone tried to punch
you if someone grabbed you who would you
call
okay
the police you call him Senor Andrew Mr
Tate King Master supreme leader of
everything the university said all of
that no I just say this but nobody keeps
him chill yeah
do you not think that way since that
respect wait wait okay wait one second
one second I just said you go ahead if
you want to say something just doing the
most of course I have to do the most
this is the thing what you don't
understand is that as a lady I am
displaying to you that it's very easy to
speak to a man like Andrew Tate as long
as you don't need to step on his toes
and you expect you respect the authority
that he has I'm not gonna sit here and
try and fight against the man that has
done a lot more in my life been in rooms
I haven't been in because he's Andrew
Tate I respect you but I can still pop
my point across okay my point is no but
there is a point of course when you say
but after something you just can't say
nothing however it's a point it's an
acknowledgment and then comes the
counter argument because I don't have to
agree with things to speak okay so my
Point simply is fine I get that but at
the end of the day the same way that we
have evolved now as a woman I have
evolved I I would expect and what I do
want is not equality is a certain level
of respect which means that if I am also
somebody that is quite smart somebody
that can take care of themselves I've
done all of this for about 30 years of
my life you can't tell me just no but
what the condition is sorry yeah the
condition is instead of telling me no
give me the Assurance as to why you said
no because actually I am agreeable when
you make me feel assured that what
you're doing makes me feel safe actually
because what women are looking in love
for is stability
it doesn't count if you're only
agreeable when you feel like being
agreeable
can I just say something submission
when you feel like being agree like when
you feel it can I just say something
else out of respect we live in different
houses of course if I went here never
know me and my man because I I'm a
caregiver if I if I went he would have
never known right so I still didn't go
okay
and
so what you were saying so I'll say to
you okay baby you don't need to go why
don't you mean to go like what's
worrying what's the matter why would you
not want me to go but why would I want
to question him when he's always got my
best interest at home well I want to
know he's not I don't know why because
my best interesting why should he have
to explain everything because you're not
a child you are I also want to know
a woman like she doesn't have her own
mind it's very different acknowledgment
I'm sorry think about it right I'm a 26
I'm 26 right yeah I've lived my life all
by myself and then I'm in a relationship
and this man is telling me I can't go
does that make sense can I do that to a
man and just say I don't want you I told
him if I told my man listen right you
know you said you're going such and such
well you know what I don't really think
you should go you'll think about it and
he'll say you really don't want me to go
and I'll say no it won't go that's a lie
that's not a lie there's no matter
let me give you let me baby let me ask
you girl let me ask you girls a question
the reason she decided not to go is
because this is obviously not a regular
occurrence right so he had a reason and
she trusts his judgment let me give you
girls a scenario let's imagine I'm with
a chick whatever whatever she has a
concert I say I don't want you to go and
she she replies like you why can't I go
and I say
got a bad feeling don't go now what now
so which would you think the woman
should just go I don't give a [__] about
your stupid feeling and bounce
the reason it might wait there's no
reason there's no reason
this is the thing it doesn't make sense
listen my sister this is the key when
you say I don't know I just call a bad
feeling let me tell you how that is get
translated into my head he cares about
me and he's actually thinking about
something that potentially could be
happening that I'm not aware of I love
him for thinking outside the box but
you've reassured me you've shown me
respect for being able to provide your
decisions and that's all it takes that's
all it goes no but I'm sorry logical
reason as to why you're going to tell me
I feel it I'm feeling a bad feeling a
feeling is
the whole point
the whole point is a guy doesn't want to
explain like what every decision he
makes
a lot of times like men think things
through a lot like more than we realize
and so he's already thought about it
he's already made his decision it's a
headache to him when every time he makes
a decision he has to explain it to you
that's right
if you trust that man and you've been
with him as long as Auntie's been with
her man and he says something with the
kind of relationship they have and the
respect they have for each other of
course she's gonna be like all right
well cool Don that's trust and that's
trust I wasn't happy of course and also
that's that's a really good point about
submission because submissions is
largely misunderstood like I can tell
you a million stories I've had girls who
are like yeah you're the man you're in
charge and yeah no problem did uh yeah
she's cool she's cool on the jet she's
cool in Dubai she's cool in the
restaurants she's cool in the five stars
she's cool in the lambo but the second I
say something that she that she'd half
doesn't like then she's like well you
know what that's the feminist right so
women do this very well a lot of women
flip-flop like if you trust your man and
you really want to be with him and you
really want to submit to him there's
going to be times you're going to submit
in ways you don't like that's the whole
point of it yeah two things you don't
want to do I've actually said this in
the past I respect you in the fact that
you're willing to give a woman a life
you're willing to provide for her so I
respect that you can then tell her I
want you to do this baby but she has to
live you're right but a lot of women
they want autonomy over themselves
personally I don't want a man that's
going to provide for me just so he can
tell me to sit down and I'm a dog let's
make my own decisions let's understand
something every man
it's just a matter of whether you're
happy with not everybody no no exactly
every man will give you a life it's just
a matter of whether you're happy with
the man the life that man is capable of
giving and this goes back into the
earlier points we were saying you can
find a good man who will work his ass
off and give you the best life he can
possibly give you give you every ounce
of strength inside of him he'll give you
all he has you can get that but if
you're gonna wake up and go no I don't
want that life I want that life well
then that comes with problems
this is the cognitive dissonance that
most females operate under where they
sit and go I want that life but I want
him to act like that guy I want the
Nissan and the McLaren you can't have
both what about you need to decide and
there becomes a degree of female
maturity as you said earlier you get to
a point where you're like you know what
maybe all that Glitz and Glam and
[__] is it worth it it's not worth
it you grow up right and and that's
fantastic and you make a different
decision and I'm saying that a lot of
women get to that point the problem is
in the modern world the [__] women did
before they got to that point from 19 to
pisses the man off to the point where
he's never gonna be as good as he could
be it's different in your in your world
right you met a man you stick with it
man dig I know plenty of people first
man High School sweethearts the world
was different only 40 50 years ago the
second man they've been married forever
50-year marriages all that shit's gone
and then we have to tie back into all
the other sub points I've made into
you've had a very fun life at your Peak
sexual value from 19 to 24 running
around doing XYZ now you're with this
guy who can't give you the life he knows
you've already lived part of him feels
inferior his status is damaged because
all the [__] you did is on Instagram and
he ain't the one who gave it to you and
now you're expecting a whole bunch of
crap out of him and now when he comes
and works his ass off and manages to
save up and buy a BMW and picks you up
hey I got a BMW you go
yeah I like Mercedes and this is the
point you're missing it's all about the
[__] car it's about something larger
than that it's about making him feel
like he's a man again and that he's in
charge
I'm an autonomous female I can [__] it
like that but you're what are you doing
you're damaging the psyche of the man
who's trying to love you is it worth it
break it down
does loving mean that you listen to what
I have to say and also think about what
I want and not just what you want is
that what loving means if that's it I
can I can subscribe to that but I'm not
gonna subscribe to you sit down and you
have to sit down I'm a grown ass woman I
pay my own bills and you're gonna tell
me what to do that's fine but it gets to
a point it gets to a point where you
have to sit and analyze the scenario
you're in and try and realize and pick
your battles and I'm telling you you may
not realize it but a man does a whole
bunch of [__] for you that you don't
know he's watching the shows you want to
watch He's listened to you talk gossip
about the girls at work he's [__]
going yeah I like that dress that dress
he doesn't give a [__] about any of it
he's doing it for you but the second is
back the other
you have some [__] issue
listen yeah he's right because women
women talk nonsense
you're right yeah baby can't believe she
did that it's true babe oh yeah that
show is good yeah babe yeah it's true
a lot about women do a lot too as much
as my if my man caters to me I will do
anything to make him happy if he says oh
babe I wanna I like this meal I will I
will make sure I can cook it for him
because guess what he actually cares
about what I want as well you can't just
have a one-way relationship hey I'm just
saying
I'm just saying if I was a woman and I
had to make a man as attracted to me as
possible my goal would be to give that
man status and make him feel good about
himself and I'd be very very careful
talking too much about life experiences
or opposing views not because he's out
to oppress me not because he's an evil
horrible person but because he's trying
to find somebody with a similar Life
View he's trying to find somebody he can
show the world to trying to find
somebody can feel like he can teach
things too that's how you get the best
out of a man I'll tell you how I get the
best stuff that's why I got Clementine
no no no but if you go into a man's room
when he's playing video games and he's
playing video games and you say all you
do is play video games then you nag him
he'll play video games if you walk in
there and go you know what you're so
smart I've seen you do so many amazing
things and you've said so many amazing
things why do you waste your time
playing video games you could show me so
much now you're gonna get him off the
[__] console yeah but it's an E I
know it's an ego play I know your old
girls are like why should I have to do
that there's a lot of things it tells
you a little pretty in the morning
because you win
it's because in the end you win did you
talk about why should I have to do that
well why should you have to work hard in
the gym to get six-pack because you win
that's the game if you it's actually men
are so simple we are so simple and the
truth is women know it this is what's
amazing women pretend they're confused
you're not confused you know you're just
egos are in the way and Society is
telling you something else and you just
[__] refuse to be agreeable nice
people
why man up this [__]
problems
wait wait wait so I have a question for
the girls so imagine you're dating a guy
okay and it's your birthday and for your
birthday he gets you let's say a 500
gift
okay and you're you're happy right it's
very it's thoughtful it's specific to
you then you found out last year
he got his ex-girlfriend an entire
birthday party
how does that make you feel he she he
went he did the most he he rented out
the nicest hotel in London he got her
everything she wanted the year before
Mina care you don't care
as long as he's making me happy okay
you're different we're different people
too it's a different relationship and
maybe like you know he he bought her
flowers every day 365 days a year and he
didn't do that for me it's like well if
that's what makes her happy he's gonna
do it makes her happy I mean I get I get
the angle what you're saying is like oh
he she did you know he did all that for
her why am I not good enough but the
second you compare yourself you lose
yeah yeah and I I agree but I'm just
saying that's how men look at like your
past is like basically like you've given
it for free okay so here's my question
to that because all right I love like
everything we're talking about okay so
to all the viewers out there including
myself right
you live life there's gray area you live
and you [__] learn right
so where the [__] do we go from here so
do I play the shame game where everybody
walks away a [__] loser because I can
do that I've beat myself up my entire
life for every decision I've ever made
right it got me nowhere no so I I value
myself I see the world differently
through a series of events right
so what the [__] comes next because
that's where I'm confused right because
I'm not it's like I did if you don't if
it's not like gifted to you like even in
your situation like your dad provided
you a life that like so many people
would kill for like you know what I mean
so that's why it's like
it's sucks because the reason I hate
these conversations is because it's
never about like empathy do I understand
the the the scales and how someone may
view for this this that and the third
okay but moving forward then what so
okay so I'm I'm just gonna like I said
make it about myself I'm 30 single mom
my [__] checkered pass is all over
Instagram you know what I mean I have
people like you or she's a hoe she's a
she's literally known for this okay
so what would what would be your advice
to people like me then I don't believe
in gray area I believe black and white
okay that's unfortunate because there is
Greg
there's great I do know what to answer
it I'm gonna answer it I mean I just
think there's consequences for your
decisions and I just think like my best
advice would be to like lower your
standards
like that because because I just think
there's going to be consequences for
putting you know promiscuous stuff on
the internet okay and you probably won't
get the type of guy that you could have
got at 22. do you know why it wasn't
meant to be then do you know what I'll
tell you I would say because I'm 30 and
I'm single out of a situation that
actually is not because I was a hoe and
I was doing whatever whatever people
can't call me that I made it my decision
to be with somebody that hurt me alone I
stayed for five years I came out super
late and you know what I realized what
my what what I learned is that I know
now that I have to be selective and I
have to think if me taking longer to get
to that stage Is What It Takes then
that's what it takes you accept your
future you accept everything with
gratitude because as long as you're
breathing that's the most important
thing at least you've got your child I
am not afraid because I know the quality
of women that I am I know my value
regardless of whether I'm 30 40 50. do
you understand so you don't be afraid by
other people's time limits and
limitations and all of these things
because it actually doesn't matter and
I'll tell you why now that your value
goes down
like no but I'm saying
I'll tell you why because since Mr
Andrew Tate explained something about
status I understand very well what that
actually means and as a woman the
quality and the value that I hold for
myself is actually the kind of value and
quality that a man will appreciate the
status you'll bring to him whether or
not I'm a virgin because I've worked on
myself to be a woman of quality and
substance I respect myself and I handle
myself as such okay and that is the way
that you're going to actually overcome
all of these bad mistakes that you've
made because who you are right now
actually will make a difference if you
stick to it and if you mean it and if
you've always been that way there's
always another another story for
everybody it doesn't matter you'll be a
fan that's more emotionally mature you
know I would say to you what are you
about to say Andrew because you just
started speaking I want to say um I want
to hear I really because because you've
been through a lot in your life like
when I when she told me that you were
going to be on and we were going to be
on this panel together I started
watching a bunch of your videos and it
really was like there's so much that you
have been through which is why you have
a well of of wisdom right and the
difference between me and you is that
you're glorified for it and I am burned
at the stake for everything that I've
been through and I it's so funny because
people have always said that we were two
sides of the same coin as far as like
well if Andrew tank gets bambering your
energy get banned because there's we are
all about accountability and [__]
truth right yeah okay so you've been
through a lot I've been through a lot
I'm seen as used Goods you're seen as a
high value man so if you're me then then
what what's next yeah it's really
interesting and it's interesting you
make the observation and you are correct
that's the difference between the
masculine and The Feminine it's kind of
it's unfair I guess the world's not fair
but that's the difference in Damascus
and The Feminine men are respected for
going through things and surviving and
women are the complete opposite they're
shame for going through things and
surviving if you look at women love
scars on men for a reason he's gone
through something here they're War
wounds yeah men don't want a chick
covered in scars I'll say this right now
that a woman the more trauma she goes
through the more masculine she naturally
becomes and if you were to give me my
ideal woman I would not want of of
wanting her to have a hard life and a
bunch of trauma I like the idea of her
having a soft feminine life and being a
soft person and I can take care of her
and protect her whereas as a man to be a
good man you need to have been through a
bunch of trauma because if you haven't
been through trauma as a man you're a
weakling you have to have been through a
bunch of [__] so the masculine the
feminine is a very interesting point
there as for
I don't know I don't know your history I
don't know the past but we can just talk
in general generalizations in regards
people like me I guess under the same
umbrella I don't know any of it but
we'll give generalizations one of the
main reasons that men are scared of a
female with history is is because it
makes demand insecure and and scared
dogs bite so this is why men will snap
or get angry quick or they'll bring up
your if you if you get an argument with
him he'll bring up your history that
whatever but a lot of it is insecurity
and it's not insecurity because the man
is insecure the woman the women the
female Paradigm in society convinces men
any man who says anything you're
insecure it's not insecure in that way
it's insecure in a very realistic
logical way like I was saying earlier
she's had a lot of life experience let's
be honest am I the richest guy she's
ever had no am I the most famous guy
she's ever had no am I the best looking
guy she's ever had no like what's
keeping her here and then part of it
comes down to well at my second place
could if she could do better would she
do better like there's a whole bunch of
insecurity involved and that's where
tiny things like I'm talking I know it
sounds like dumb [__] tiny things about
the favorite car brand become more
important than ever right it's it's your
job as a woman regardless of how much
sexual history you've had or what guy
you're with Etc it's your job as a woman
to make your man feel secure in the fact
and make him feel like a man like Auntie
was saying make him feel like the man no
matter what he does so that he feels
like you really truly believe he's the
best choice for you on the planet that's
your job to do now if you've had a
checkered past that's perhaps more
difficult you need to be more tactful
with it more tactical about it but you
have to achieve the same result you have
to do the exact same thing right so yeah
it's easy for me if I get a a 21 year
old virgin from some Village in Slovakia
and I'm multi-millionaire Andrew Tate of
course it's a very easy she's never had
better she'll never get better she's
never been anywhere boom boom easy one
right but like you said the world's not
so so so idealistic the reality is that
people have had relationships etc etc
but a man is happiest in the
relationship when he feels like man in
the house and when he truly feels like
you believe he's the best man that you
could possibly ever get and have ever
gotten because a man is jealous I'll
tell you something
I used to say this to girls it's like a
joke
I just said no if I say it's a joke so
you cheated on me before I met you
and she'd be like what do you mean I
didn't even know you was like yeah you
[__] that guy before I even knew you
beat it on me and they used to laugh
whatever but that's how men think that's
the male mind like I love you and you've
been [__] by who but I didn't know you
I don't care if you knew me you should
have weigh it what do you mean that's
the male mind so he is it competition
with all of your exes and all of your
lifestyle and all the things you've done
permanently and it's down to you as a
woman to sit there and go how do I make
him secure in himself and secure in his
masculinity and make him believe that
investing in me is still worthwhile
because I still truly value him despite
the fact that I could do XYZ I hope that
gives some clarity but that's that's the
answer you know what I would have said I
would have said oh for anybody in that
situation come off social media and just
Raise Your Child So the next the person
who meets you've got nothing to but I
never knew you I never knew who you were
because I don't I've never heard of you
before so when I spoke to you
by the way people by the way you're
saying like what's on us on the internet
let me say you're a nicer person than
what you sound like like what you
perceive to be like you were saying oh
the Pearl's go there she's a horse she's
a [__] and I've heard I've heard the
name but I don't know anything about you
and I was saying that if you didn't have
nothing on social media about your
checkered past and you met somebody the
same way how I met you and I Converse
and I got to know you it's the same way
that they would
yeah and and it is interesting and it's
also back to Damascus and feminine right
because I'm all over the Internet and
supposedly I'm misogynist and I'm evil
and all this crap right but if I meet of
a girl even if she disagrees with me in
fact I'll say this I've never ever met a
single female who's ever come out to me
and disagree with me every woman comes
up to me and loves what I says but let's
imagine I met this imaginary girl she
was sitting me and if I were to have a
10 minute conversation with her by the
time I explained the level to which they
tried to destroy me how they tried to
freeze all my bank accounts raise
illegal charges against me put me in
jail for things I didn't do put a travel
ban take my passport all this garbage by
the time I explain how hard they tried
to hurt me and failed she'll want me
because she'll be like you can't kill
this guy
like you say a bunch of [__] I don't
like but you know what you're you're the
man so it's it is about experience and
it is different and that's a really good
point about social media social media
amplifies all of this [__] it amplifies
all these problems everything we're
discussing everything we've discussed
back to the beginning from status to
promiscuity to your past it's all social
media without social video a lot of it
goes away and I think that's why me and
my man laughed so long is that he
doesn't do social media and there's
nothing on there about me I feel like to
answer your question too because I have
had people
say that as a solution and it's like you
can run but you cannot hide from the
truth and I have shared why my voice has
been so impactful and will continue to
be impactful is because I have put
myself out there and I have been
punished for being honest so it's like I
have been giving a platform given a
platform and a voice for a reason even
sitting down in this conversation
thinking there's not one person I'm
probably gonna agree with and probably
going to want to leave
um I have been called here for a reason
so it's like I can't go against what is
in my heart and what I am coded to be
and that's why I feel like it's
important for me to sit here and
represent people who feel like me
because it's like I didn't I don't want
to say I didn't I don't want to say that
um I just feel like I don't see a lot of
women Under My Umbrella who feel the way
that I feel I don't see opinion shared
that I that would be worded the way that
I feel nothing I feel like a lot of my
thoughts are very unique and it's it's
kind of scary because I have been
through different things I I see the
world in a different place and when I
even even speak online people think I'm
[__] speaking Swahili yeah so it's
like and I know no and I know exactly
what you're saying and you're making
good points and it's just I think that
regardless of whether like we're talking
about different positions I compare
everything to chess I know it's annoying
we're looking at different positions on
the chess board but the rules are still
the same right okay no matter how bad
your position is or how good your
position is you're still trying to
achieve the same objectives and and you
want you want the man to get high status
and you want the man to feel secure in
himself and I think it's it's very
difficult I can only talk from the male
perspective because I am a man it is
very difficult if artemi a woman who I
liked very much but she had X whatever
pass whatever my concerns would be how
do I know that I'm still the number one
how do I know I'm most important in her
life especially if I don't measure up in
certain key metrics and two the second
thing that's most scary for men is we
understand that men are constantly after
what we have like your inboxes are all
full like they may not be with guys you
want to reply to but guys are still
trying to get it that's the male life
the male life is people are trying to
take everything from me and and that's
very scary and you have to make your man
really believe like that's impossible if
a man truly believes that nobody can
take you from him he's going to love you
in a different way it you can give me
you can give me two carbon copies of the
same chick but one I think might cheat
in the right circumstances and one I
know no matter what would never leave me
the love I'll feel for this one is a
different planet to the love I'd feel
for this one even though the same person
right because that's every man's biggest
fear is a woman cheating or leaving
because there's something visceral and
something different about it I know I
talk things and I say men can do things
and women can't and all this stuff but
like if a woman cheats on a man that
hurts the man on a level that it doesn't
hurt the woman if the man shoots on her
it's different it's it's different
biologically it's different it's
different evolutionarily like that's
what men used to fight and die over you
talk to my chick you look at myself yeah
it's like you do masculinize him on
every level like and this is why you see
these tick tocks right you see these
tick tocks me and my man went on a break
got back together he [__] 20 girl and
now he's crying because I went on a date
yes completely yes
level is different
things so you have to understand the
paradigms you have to understand to play
the game and that's how you make men
happy and I know very well how I like to
believe that I know I would know very
well how to make a woman happy and and I
know and whether I do that or not is a
conscious decision and that's where you
get to a certain level of grand Mastery
where I if I get a woman I will
literally decide out of 10 how happy do
I want her do I want does she deserve to
be happy 10 or should I keep her like
crying half the time that it's very
conscious and women don't think that way
but I'm saying if you're a smart if
you're a cutting woman you can be like
that you could be a bit more like you
know what I want him infatuated with me
this guy ain't worth the time that guy I
want and then when you're gonna do that
just like the game of chess if you play
chess it's not big moves that make you
lose it's small positional plays it's
that time you argued about your favorite
car it's a time you disagree with him
about the favorite band it's the dumb
[__] that adds up whereas really
truthfully if you're truly smart about
the game you can get him to a point
after a few months where he's like she's
my soul mate she loves everything I love
will you think the same our hearts are
connected boom and then you're safe just
don't [__] it up from there but I just
feel like it's so contradicting to feel
like what your overall message is which
is about truth so it's like if if my
truth like if it can be destroyed by the
truth it should be destroyed by the
truth so that's why I'm trying to figure
out like why it's it's really
mind-boggling to me because I feel like
how could you even be mentally
emotionally sexually stimulated by a
woman who is just agreeable and you know
it just it doesn't have her own mind I
just don't see that that is exactly that
is exactly that is exactly what every
man wants we don't want you to be
complete robots we're not saying we
can't have a joke with you we can't say
we can't have a laugh with you we're not
saying can't have a personality but when
it comes to things like agreement there
is not a single man in the world who's
gonna say she's too agreeable she just
agrees with me on it she agrees me on
all the important things in my life
she's too agreeable I want someone else
[__] no you're completely wrong on that
point it's a huge point you this idea
that I understand if you're a complete
doormat and you set no standards men
might walk all over you I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about
agreeability and agreeableness as a
whole men love the idea of a agreeable
woman because it gives status and it
makes the man feel like he's a teacher
and makes a man feel in charge and it
satisfies his ego and to you they may be
small little tiny points but to him
they're a big deal if I were to sit I'm
telling you right now if I were to sit
with with one of my chicks or whatever
or my chick and I'll just sit in the
lambo and say lambo's the best car of
all of my preferred label she goes I
don't like that one like listen I bought
them all and I [__] said it's the
best one shut up it would annoy me
because that's my reality I want her to
become part of my reality it's the thing
and you talk about truth it's
interesting because the truth of your
heart and the truth of your soul is to
be happy that's truth truth is for you
to end up happy now if you have to sit
there and agree on especially on a
subject you don't give a [__] about
right if it's something you care about
and you are very knowledgeable about if
it's ancient Roman history and you have
a degree in ancient Rome then fine argue
the point but if it's cars or something
you don't even give a [__] about Mickey
what yeah you're missing the chance to
get points on the scoreboard easy free
throw and you're just [__] it up
going oh no no why why the truth is just
just play the game and win you're gonna
be the best female dating I'll just
learn a couple of words like how many
talks horsepower just throw some words
in how much horsepower is it that's it
okay with all due respect Not all men
are like that some men respect a woman
that has their own mind I know you and
the type of men that you're speaking on
behalf of let me tell you something like
a woman that I understand I agreeable to
everything he says like I've dated and
that just respect that I can make
decisions that will actually submissive
women have their own mind yeah
completely there's sometimes that he
might be discussing stuff that he might
want to be discussed and then sometimes
we're like shut the [__] up and let me
say what I got to say yes and maybe I
don't even believe in star signs but my
man's Sagittarius so I want this logical
stuff and feelings and emotions and no
you don't cry about [__] shut up get on
with it yes
completely and submissive women have
their own mind but you're something else
you have to take into consideration and
this is super important and super true
the reason a lot of women don't truly
understand a lot of things about
relationships and and how it works with
men Etc it's because men will lie to you
men lie for the same reason you wear
makeup because men fall in love with
what they see men fall in love with what
they see and women fall in love with
what they hear so we will lie to you so
you'll go on a date with a guy and
you'll sit there and say I don't listen
to No I'm I'm independent and what's
that man gonna say oh I love that that's
exactly the kind of woman I want come
suck this it's a [__] lie that is not
what he wants there it's not what he
wants I'm telling you this one for now
yeah he'll he can't be bothered to argue
with you at dinner because he doesn't
because and you know what most men
aren't smooth enough to do it I can sit
with a chick and disagree with her and
be funny enough and smart enough and
charismatic enough and I'm high status
enough and she respects me enough to
listen but if I'm just some normal dude
and I start arguing with the chick she's
going to bounce on the dinner and say
[__] you yeah good to see you so most
dudes dating strategy most dude's mating
strategy is just pure agreement yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
anything to get the puss because they're
[__] dorks that's fine that that
that's the truth right a real G will sit
there and say what do you mean I don't
want to hear this [__] I'm telling you
the Baseline of how men truly function
if I'm expected to fight and die to
protect you because that's what is
expected of Me by society and of you you
may think you don't expect that of me
but if we're walking down through London
the middle of the night and two guys
come up with machets you're gonna hide
behind me knowing I'm gonna die because
I can't win this fight I'm expected to
die to protect you well then I expect
you to agree with me I'm not here to
[__] die for somebody who disagrees
with me on everything that's not what
I'm here to [__] if I have that
obligation to die on the spot for you
you have the obligation to pretend you
like BMWs so do your [__]
and shut up and yeah and that's the
bottom line and you know the difference
is the only difference
between him and my mind and the level of
respect is money that's that's the only
difference and this is the same way he
talks the same way
people say like Mama only owns 4500 so
he can't talk to me away Andrew take
talks to his why not completely I know I
think my name is a big factor though
you can't have a woman that's paying her
own bills she's doing everything for
herself I mean she's a man and then
you're gonna tell her of course but
we'll do this but you you're different
she doesn't need to work you take all
that stress away from me then she'll be
a lot worse
why does money have to matter for
submission
enough money to make sure that she
doesn't need to work go and deal with
her boss every day I don't know this
stress all these bills then of course
she's going person look up to you and be
like okay he pays my bills my members
only about 40 000. I'm so I just never I
grew up in a one percent family I never
expected a dude to pay for everything
but my mom still submitted to my dad
like it wasn't the guy the point is this
in every relationship that's beautiful
every relationship that's Happy
regardless of the social economic scale
regardless of how rich or poor they are
regardless of how famous they are
regardless of how whatever in every
relationship where people are truly
happy pay attention the man is in charge
he's the top G of that house his woman
makes him feel that way she respects him
for what he does and they are happy
we're talking about me out here in the
world social media whatever it doesn't
matter every man wants to be the man of
his household the king of his castle
every single happy relationship is the
same I genuinely implore you to name a
happy relationship with a woman's in
charge name one you can't they end up
broken up the [__] she leaves him
whatever the name a happy relationship
where the woman doesn't blindly say okay
I won't go to that concert name one
there is only one framework in which
people are happy with the man in charge
the woman trusts and respects him enough
to let him be in charge and they're a
happy couple in relationship any other
type of relationship is a time bomb to
the end so if you want a happier
relationship that's what you should be
aiming for you need to be thinking you
need to be perspicacious enough and
think about these things and sit and go
well that's the only way relationships
work so I need to build it that way I
think instead of coming along and
believing you're going to reinvent the
wheel okay
[Music]
I want to hit one more topic because
we're running out of time so so I want
to actually give
the ladies a chance to say what do you
guys disagree with
um from the red pill and Men Centric
content
can I go first no
[Laughter]
you can go first I'm not really familiar
with all of the topics I'm assuming like
the stuff that you guys talk about and
consider the red pill
um it's not even like about like
disagreeing I think
you I can respect someone's point of
view and understand where that truth
exists for a lot of people and I just
feel like okay cool like I don't I don't
know I don't really disagree it's just a
perspective on life I'm not here to be
like you're wrong for thinking like that
you're wrong for categorizing using
disco using that like it's a perspective
it's valid and I totally see certain
angles like there's a lot of stuff that
was said that I mean there's so many
people on this panel it's hard to talk
but it's like there's a lot of things
I've said okay maybe I don't agree with
just because again my Walk of Life and
what I've seen and how I feel and what
how I choose to be empathetic towards
people regardless of whatever they've
been through but I don't really it's
more for you it's the lack of empathy
sometimes yeah I think that's probably
it okay yeah
um I'm gonna let Esther go
see what I don't really agree with is
the insole culture of men feeling like
they're entitled to a woman
a lot of men don't look good they don't
got money they don't do anything for
themselves and they expect women to want
to have sex with them women to want to
be with them why should she want to be
with you let me ask you a very important
why yeah let me ask you a very important
question those delusional men
do they sleep with women
of course not okay but but they get
angry you see them in Pals comments
she's a modern woman it's like no she
does doesn't want you because you are a
low life get over it go and work go to
the gym go work on yourself go out and
get a job go and get some money
that's how it is that's where most of
the men's Centric content tells guys to
do go to the gym get your money up like
that sort of thing learn game no but
that's not what they're doing what
they're doing is saying oh women are
delusional oh women want this no why
women know what they want if you want
those women go and do what they want you
don't want and then you'll be chosen you
don't have to worry about the men that
aren't getting laid and all the women
are ignoring okay yeah YouTube comments
but besides YouTube comments they have
no voice in society and they don't exist
and nobody gives a [__] right so this is
what I was saying earlier about about
reality slaps men in the face and shows
them their place very quickly because
all these men reality is showing them
their place there are women who are
disagreeable and unlikable and doing
wrong things and acting badly and
[__] up how to make a man attract to
them and they're not being slapped in
the face by reality because they're
still ending up with a partner so this
is the point we're trying to make here I
agree I know thing about red pill is a
whole bunch of bitter hate-filled guys I
agree with that yes can I just drop
another comment when I came on your show
they were in my
in my post little comments and then come
into my my social media and then explain
in my DMs like you really have nothing
to do without hitting on you or were
they like oh no they were calling me
Miss Sandra some girls get hit on even
after the insults because
we just don't want people I get over it
that's just the internet though like I
get death threats I get like people make
videos it's just I mean I just think
like you go on the internet duh like
yeah you're gonna get insulted on the
internet
who hasn't been but it's obviously it's
quite hard especially when you're
receiving a lot of hate from all these
men I mean
I've had hundreds of videos made on Tick
Tock like that go after my appearance it
happens to me like every time
one one I called her a whale after she
attacked me after she she attacked me
she knocks the mic out of my hand she
called me a slack I didn't know what
that meant at the time okay I had no
idea what that meant she called me a
slag put the mic out of my so of course
I'm gonna call her will you you attacked
me first that's what they never talk
about you got cold because you attacked
me I missed a good episode it sounds
like it was a street interview and this
girl she like knocks the mic out of my
hand and they're pulling her back you
have you you slag and I was like you're
effing female but it was like it was
like that was a response I've never
called someone on my show a whale
individually but when I come with you
I'll show you were quite rude to me
um I'm not gonna lie no I'm not gonna
lie the way you conduct your like show
today today was great but when I was on
your show last time you were like why
you talk too much I'm thinking who is
this woman talking to me like that I'm
not a child but that's the thing because
you kept interrupting everybody the
whole show no that's what happened
is because I'm the host yeah and so so
today it's like we have we have a big
guest oh I'm gonna I'm gonna let him
talk but you're in no offense you're
just a normal guest and normal guest we
don't let dominate the entire
conversation
you you you you were you probably talked
70 of the time and so I have to
interrupt you and stop you because
you're talking and nobody else in the
room and nobody else in the room had a
chance to talk I understand I interrupt
people but that's part of your job as a
host is to control the conversation and
if anything I probably control the
conversation less than I should compared
to most hosts no but I think it's the
way that you were rude you could just be
like okay let the next person talk you
were like why you talk to me that is so
weird because because
we had tried we had tried multiple times
to tell you nicely
multiple times to tell you nicely and it
just had to ask it just kept escalating
that is not true I think you're trying
to guess like me right now because
that's not true the thing is you didn't
agree what I was saying and then you
resulted you and Auntie resulted to
insults
but that's the reason I would say I'm
not coming for you right now because you
know what it's your show but what I'm
trying to say for us but you're not
coming for us no just open your mouth
listen listen what I'm trying to say
what I'm trying to say is
no how was I rooty why you called my
name into I was I rude to you but you
were rude how was Our Roots you were
rude this is this is just my point of
view you you told a story where you said
another you didn't say you're too nice
about it you'll find it too nice
you're coming to show all right I don't
care right now because you're on the
streets
calm down don't tell me about calm down
hang on I had Mr Tate talking right with
passion right and loud I had no way time
to calm down right you're there shouting
off your mouth right I am very loud I am
being loud all right don't tell me about
calm down because when he was talking
who was just screeching that listen
right as far as I'm concerned don't even
think about coming on per show and
disrespecting her you've done it already
and now you're coming back here to do it
again Pearl wasn't rude to you she was
right I wasn't rude to you yes you know
what because he spoke the truth
because at the end of the day it's all
out there if you don't know what a woman
is and you can't say what a woman
have some money
[Music]
okay all right guys let's take a second
to hear from our Channel sponsor
identity theft can be a nightmare
situation if it ever happens to you one
victim from San Francisco described her
experience after losing her wallet at a
bar apparently I stole a Tesla I got in
a car accident with it I got a new
iPhone I opened two new checking
accounts and went on a bad check writing
spree for as much as thirteen thousand
dollars at a time I attempted to open
dozens of new credit cards I wrote a
check for someone's bail which they
skipped and so on it took this victim
years and heavy amounts of stress to her
life to undo what the thieves did to her
if she would have had an identity
protection at the time she could have
mitigated some of the damage that the
thieves were able to do to her stories
like this are happening all over the
world and you have to be on high alert
to protect yourself one way to protect
yourself with identity from identity
theft is with virtual Shield one it
monitors banking retirement and
investment institutions for potential
data breaches dark web scans social
security protection with 24 7 alerts and
can protect you and your family with up
to a one million dollar insurance policy
virtual Shield one includes free access
to Virtual Shield's industry-leading VPN
with unlimited VPN access and advanced
VPN plus features to keep your internet
and cell browsing activity Anonymous and
private the service also includes
malware and ad blocking with a 30-day
free trial and 67 off this holiday
season what do you have to lose I use it
myself and love how it makes me feel
safe by protecting my identity and
keeping my browsing history Anonymous
just click the link below or simply
visit
www.virtualshield.com pearly that's
www.virtualshield.com pearly and protect
your identity today remember supporting
my sponsor supports this channel thank
you guys again I just think we're going
to see that situation differently I
don't think I was rude to you I actually
think I was quite polite but that's just
my opinion you think I was rude okay I
was just trying to explain why the women
came from
to be fair then you called me racist and
sexist
[Music]
let's go back to the topic your
disagreement with the red pill
oh so the insult you don't you don't
like the bad comments okay no no no no
not the bad comments the fact that they
just feel entitled when women say what
they want they feel so entitled that
women need to change that it's like no
women like what they like just like a a
man likes a woman that looks good A man
that a woman that cooks a woman that's
younger like he said someone has not
been traumatized has not been through so
much experience like we don't cry about
it you know yes you know what we do you
know what women do yes yes wait wait I
need I need to stop you there yes we do
what is body positivity what is [__]
shaming we do cry about it and we cry
about it loud on every social media
platform we do yeah there's no there's
no other way I'm just gonna give you an
equivalent there's no short man shaming
no you don't hear the man crying about
that
about it no they don't yes they do
there's you do you see a short man being
pushed to be on the cover of magazines
where they say we we need more short men
short short male models oh I see what
you mean where they're they're putting
plus-sized women on the cover of
magazines
[Music]
I think I think he's like five eight to
five ten which is average actually like
most women don't know only 15 of men
over six foot yeah okay but I think
everyone
what they have like you know what if you
if you don't have money like own it be
happy with yourself
that's okay
I that it's fine I agree with you but
I'm saying like men have to deal with
the consequences like an average chick
can still sleep with an NBA player
who's like a top top 10. okay okay okay
I'll give you I'll give you I'll give
you an example okay I I've I've had guys
on that level message me I think I'm an
average chick I would never in my right
mind think that any of them would take
me like oh you're rich but but
what's your money men don't care about
you they know they don't they don't they
don't dance
she's from a rich background
I personally don't like bumps that's
just not my thing that might be your
thing okay you want a high value
I'm saying I don't I don't like guys
that don't have jobs just just just can
I just say something it's gonna shock
everybody
I would like to hear what the novels got
to say no oh my God you know how much
I'll be holding on to my feet like is it
my turn to unleash everything that's
been in my head okay cool question was
again sorry what do you disagree with
from the red pill well I disagree with
the red pill movement is the fact that
it fails to understand that it has
extreme limitations because you focus a
lot on the extremities of things and I
will revert that back to me
I don't think the red pill addresses the
fact that there were a lot of housewives
that were left withered quite young and
therefore had no choice but to step up
in transition into a strong and evolved
Modern Woman and I say that because my
dad passed away when I was 12 and I
didn't have a man in my life to be able
to show me the way not only because
there's really just not many men in my
life because my mom focused her energies
and efforts into raising us and
providing for us because she didn't have
a man and I don't think it would be fair
to even expect my mom to when we were 12
13 14 to go and find a new man because
actually that creates even more issues
within the home first even to accept him
especially because we have close
relationship with my dad with that said
what the red pill movement fails to
address empathize with and look for
solution is for all the women and the
men that come from these sorts of homes
where actually it is not your fault that
you are a product of your environment so
when you were telling me about housewife
your masculine Edition that I have to
say my mom raised four daughters on her
own by my age she had the four of us
moved freshly to the UK of course she's
gonna hustle of course I'm gonna go
through education of course I'm gonna
work of course I'm gonna have to be
strong with myself because there's no
man to protect me so because I've had
this sort of background I've had this
sort of experience people tell me your
traumas are make you less likable or
maybe you're too masculine as woman no I
am a survivor of a woman actually
because I didn't have men around me and
I am actually again also capable of
being a wife I know how to cook I know
how to actually speak to my man please
him verbally and physically okay so
what's the distance
and I'll explain to you and I'll explain
to you submission side of things where
I've actually the whole show I've proved
that without having any friction with
Andrew Tate as much as you may even say
that may not be disabled or not I come
up with my own Solutions where I don't
have to compromise who I am but I can
still please you as a man you told me
your favorite car is that one even
though I like down I'm like do you know
what I like that one but looking at
yours yours is really nice too you know
I really like you got good taste it's
that simple what people explain what
people are failing to do with the Red
Bull movement is to understand that that
can be a compromise because I've had to
compromise my life as a woman to be able
to survive because I didn't have a man
about okay you think the red pill
doesn't agree with no live in compromise
no it doesn't deal with the victims of
society of situations that it's just
life okay okay
um do you have any points for them both
of those yeah I can talk about the red
bill I can complain about it just too
too I think there is I I to be fair
um I do think there is a lot of Angry
Bear men which are attracted to it uh
and those are the ones that will leave
these stupid comments my point was that
but my point is that they're already
being punished by God and by Society so
don't worry about it my point is that if
a woman doesn't act correctly she
doesn't feel the true sting of
punishment not in her prime years she
may feel it later but in her prime years
it doesn't [__] even matter which is
why they do it whereas if a man doesn't
have a [__] in order trust me he knows
very well because his realities sucks
and that's why he's sending you DMS
because he's lonely because if he had a
life he wouldn't bother right so there's
that part of it it does attract a lot of
angry bitter people but I think that's
because
life's very difficult as a man like we
said earlier and some of them end up
angry and bitter the answer to all
things I believe whether you're a man or
you're a woman to try and heal all Rifts
between the genders I think whether
you're a man or you're a woman the
answer to all things in life is to take
absolute not or self-accountability for
all the good and all the bad you must
look at yourself and realize everything
good that happened in your life is your
fault and everything bad that happens in
your life is completely your fault and
without having that high degree of
absolute accountability
it doesn't matter even if it rains
outside I blame myself because I didn't
have to be in London right I could have
gone I could have stayed in Dubai and it
wouldn't have rained so I'm responsible
for absolutely everything and if you do
that you pay attention to things and you
try your very best to mitigate the
negative circumstances and work your
hardest you're going to have a pretty
good life I just want to finish by
saying that I believe that men and women
are best as a team I don't think any
woman will be truly happy without a man
and I certainly know that no man will be
happy without a woman I think it's
absolutely beautiful we work as couples
and we create families and we stick to
our strengths when men stick to what
they're good at and a woman sticks to
what they're good at that makes them the
most powerful team on the planet
and the world we're living in now we
have societal pressures and propagandas
which are trying very hard to divide and
split the genders but truthfully the
power and the beauty of the universe
relies on us working together so
it's been very nice speaking to you
ladies I'm only upset that you ran out
of Clementines and I'm stuck I was going
to say give this man a knowledge and
those are my life there's melon out
there okay we've got melon but uh yeah
all in all I think it's I think it's
good and I I also think that discussion
is very very important and I think that
a lot of these issues are are delicate
and they're nuanced and people listening
to conversations like these and hearing
the different points of view and
understanding each other is a fantastic
way to progress and we're entering brand
new territory and it's never been done
before and perhaps you can call me
old-fashioned I don't think it's going
to be as good as it was in the olden
days but we're going to find out so
interesting
um okay thank you guys all for coming
we'll do a little round of applause for
the panel
um so why don't we go around and any
final thoughts any social media you want
to plug you can do it now so start here
and then go around
I mean I'm good
okay you already know who she is
um I have more like a request is that
okay
um could you say my name please
I can't pronounce it
that's it top G the Nova and Andrew Tate
Sagittarius team representing follow me
on the gram the Nava dot AO he said the
name so you know it's legit thank you
Pearl
um my final thoughts we've just um
reflected on everything we've been
speaking about I just think men and
women we need to listen to each other I
picked up a lot on what Tate was saying
about how women need to be a bit more
agreeable make their man feel like he's
the only one agreed
but also men need to listen to women as
well she needs to feel protected she
needs to feel like you're going to be
there you're not going to leave her for
another woman
she needs to feel secured like can we
all just listen to each other and what
we want in each other and that's the
only way we can strengthen the family
unit that's all I have to say and please
follow me yes sir your Nigerian Queen
um Auntie you want to go and then you go
see this lady are you okay Auntie
you're right
I'm cool
I just think that
my final thoughts when it's out there
it's out there you said it you said it
that's how I feel
and yes um
we've all been through trauma I'm sick
of hearing about it I don't mind if
you've got trauma you don't know but if
you know you've got trauma sort it out I
don't want to hear about it call me lack
of empathy no just like a [__] you
know you got trauma sort it out
and um
sometimes when people are talking women
need to listen
Sometimes women need to spend too much
time talking because I'm sure that half
of what Mr Tate said was totally lost or
mixed around or misunderstood and um I
don't give a [__] if anybody thinks I'm
rude this is a worm and if you don't
like it it's tough because I'm changing
my final thoughts tell them to subscribe
to your YouTube you should just hit 50.
maybe a YouTube channel yeah and um um
yeah Auntie Jenny American spelling with
the Y Jenny YouTube Instagram is nothing
on this I don't go on Instagram tell
them about your calling show oh yeah and
I have a cooling show and I'd like to
have a calling show the next one women
can fall in and disagree with anything
I've said anybody that wants the phone
in and disagree phone in life disagree
with me I'll take it whatever you
disagree with me on I'm gonna have a
disagreement show find up and disagree
with me yeah that's what I'm gonna do
because I can do it because I'm a female
OG
I learned that there doesn't sound very
agreeable I like that the other day um
Andrew do you have anything else you
want to plug yeah my Instagram oh wait
I'm banned
my Facebook band I've got Myspace anyone
got Myspace
find me on MySpace
come on Rumble yeah I was about to say
I'm on Rumble which is better than
YouTube in every way sorry YouTube
um rumble.com
Tate speech and the website is
covertape.com but uh most people tell me
listen I can't avoid your face on
Instagram or Tick Tock anyway so uh it
doesn't matter if I'm banned because I'm
still around but covertake.com I I
recommend to people if you like what I
say I have a free email list sign up to
the free email list I send an email
every single day about different topics
summer for the guys summer for the girls
but they're all on there
Tate speeches sick hate speech okay
thank you guys all for coming
um guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell make sure you sign up
for our memberships
um especially our second tier if you
want to see me freestyle rap
um sign up for the second tier of
memberships it's in the behind the
scenes Vlogs
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel
um and I'll talk to you guys next time
[Applause]